so guys this is gonna be like
big big big gameplay stream big gameplay
stream
Elwyn with the five gifteds getting us
started off with the gifted memberships
Elwyn see oh when you can't like you
just can't keep this up with us doing
more streams
you you really you don't have to keep
this up I hope you know that
oh man elven's like
she's like oh man I'm gonna have to
start working overtime here all these uh
James is doing more streams now elwin
moderator for all kinds of Hogwarts like
Legacy slash Harry Potter channels it
seems
so congrats to those of you who just got
one of the gifted memberships right
there enjoy your emotes there
oh yeah you guys like the
I was fortunate I don't know how mine
went through to get the Merlin
I got lucky oh yeah guys I forgot I
forgot we got a new uh
new backdrop here I worked on this last
night
This was um
so everybody's seen these panels before
but I saw this really cool idea this
person on Amazon had taken theirs and
like
mounted it onto a board
and then put lights on the back of it so
then you just get the lights
oh it looks so cool I almost want it on
the whole wall though but I don't know I
kind of like how it's popping out like
that Lord's Star-Lord Kirby with a 50
Super Chat
oh my goodness Kirby
dude thank you so much for the Super
Chat
welcome
wow Kirby thank you so much dude and
then Elwyn with the gifteds right there
Kirby hope you're doing well man I
didn't see a question or a comment or
anything
just a very cool little animation right
there
so if you have a if you had a question
or anything I'd love to uh happy to
answer but thank you so much for your
support man it has been a crazy couple
days let me tell you
crazy couple of days with all the the
amount of support that people have been
showing
thank you all very much and yes so uh
Karthik you you just got a gifted
membership from Ellen it looks like yeah
Karthik Levi pretty dotted pages and
then who got the other two Ellen let's
see devrel got one of them
and then Draven got one of them
so there you go those are the five right
there dreaming plays games in the house
as well
oh let's do a quick uh I'm gonna do a
real quick rundown and then I want to
get into some gameplay man I want to get
into some gameplay
I don't like the fact that now that
everybody can play I'm getting passed up
like I gotta get to the end of this game
dude we got a kashiki in the house a
cane Vision Alicia hey Alicia
you saw you saw the mooncalf you were
the first named creature for me you were
the first one uh Alva Sea Dog Cindy Lou
Who devrel member of House wrecking tour
right there Dragon Fire Dream and plays
games Dylan the real life surveiller of
activity in the house also a moderator
also a channel member uh Elizabeth
D Biagio
probably very wrong
oh Luna's arrived guys hold on she's
arrived
foreign
I thought she was still eating but nope
she wanted in
uh then we got Elwyn Johnny the hustle
puff Russell in the house Karthik
three channel members right there along
key length Long Key welcome Leia
Harrington Levi Maisie the dog there's
three members of house Dragon tour
Nathan dutt Nicholas Adler Nico the real
life Chief warlock in the house Channel
member and moderator extraordinaire
panda hat in the house tonight pretty
dotted Pages a brand new just got one of
those actually no you're not brand new
because you've got the uh
you've got the purple raconteur logo so
you've been here for at least a little
bit
uh Raisin rahimi in the house
Paula loves LFC here Rossi
what's up Rossi Rossi just has like an
insane streak of being one of the first
people to comment on every single video
I post it's like it's insanely
impressive it really is also a member of
House wrecking tour Rye Taylor in the
house Rhino super Niche member of House
wrecking tour there woola zabelin is
here and then XP lazion
all right guys
thank you all for being here and hanging
out and thank you for
wanting to hang out and watch the game
even though it's already out
thank you for uh wanting to watch a live
stream so we're on
YouTube tonight
somebody was asking do we have twitch
yes we have twitch that's how we got the
drops we streamed over on Twitch
oh my gosh yesterday all the days are
running together now yeah yesterday
we'll be back live there tomorrow
shooting for 10 10 a.m but it's really
oh she just came out or she just came
back in
you just got home
my wife just got home and now of course
Luna our dog wants to go out and greet
her
also Omar thank you for subscribing yeah
so tomorrow we'll be back on Twitch
and we'll have the drops enabled again
and then Friday I don't know
I want to try and stream Friday too but
that's like that's a that's a tough day
because I know they're doing another
stream and that's when people can get
the Merlin dropping Honestly though you
have to watch their stream for the
Merlin drop anyway plus I got some
videos to work on too so
Jamal in the house what's up Jamal yeah
we've we've upgraded from the curtains
we have upgraded
you didn't get the drop for the Merlin
ropes yeah a lot of people had had
trouble with that one
a lot of people had trouble but
fortunately for all the other cosmetic
drops for our like for the the streamer
lead ones those those worked fine so
that's that's good
all right so
we are level 24.
let's go ahead and switch the scenes
right here
foreign
watch this if I go to the um
let me adjust my camera right here
we can do this right here so then like
the whole background
oh yeah that does look nice
the thing about this game is there's not
really a good spot for the webcam
so I made it a little bit smaller and
I'm I'm trying it out in the top right
but I also feel like top left may be
better sometimes too
hold on I want the webcam yeah let's
move you up just a little bit more
you're a wizard Harry what do we have we
got more members now
you're a wizard Harry Hagrid's talking
he's saying you're a wizard so I think
that means more channel members
let's see what do we have there oh it's
just I don't know why it took them so
long to pop for those
not really sure why
but it's all good you're a wizard
congratulations welcome
oh no we don't want to move that
and then there's Lord star Kirby with
the Super Chat oh it's
oh my gosh so we finally got our OBS
working it's doing that thing again
yep yep there's Omar too where now every
single one of them
like right in the middle there
top left you think yeah I tried I'd had
top uh
top right this really the only thing you
miss in the top left is the um
when I level up I think
oh I did see that trailer Krista yeah
the new Zelda trailer
Lorena took the day off from work to
play the game woke up sick oh no but
powering through
yeah it's pretty impressive how many um
how many people are
just like totally enjoying it
well that's yeah that's true Jamal I
could put it where the mini map usually
is because I have the mini map turned
off you can actually see I turned
everything off I was just going around
earlier taking screenshots
which I posted on Twitter about this too
guys if you want to get the best
screenshots possible
just completely turn off the HUD and
then the other thing is you'll want to
make sure that you put it on Fidelity
mode because that's going to give you
the best picture and frame rate doesn't
matter when you're just taking pictures
but I am going to go and uh I'm gonna
put mine back on performance because I
just I need the frames man it does look
a lot better in Fidelity I'm not gonna
lie it looks a lot better but I need the
frames I do and then let's see I'll go
here and I'm gonna go ahead and turn on
the the spell HUD is really the only one
that I can't get by without
it's really the only one
all right so
I'm gonna I'm gonna be doing story stuff
just so everybody knows like I'm gonna
be playing through my normal normal
gameplay now on our previous YouTube
stream we were still we were doing a
countdown and I just kind of did open
World stuff because I didn't want to
spoil people who didn't have the game
yet but now people are passing me up
and we just can't have that we can't
have that hey thank you Johnny
appreciate that and also dream and plays
games with the tier one subscription or
membership or on YouTube now
thank you so much enjoy those emotes and
then also Shayan
Saha with the membership as well thank
you guys thank you well you know what I
bet that's probably why
oh we should we could put we could put
the alerts down there we'll put the
alerts down there where the mini map
would be
yeah guys welcome to house wrecking tour
welcome welcome
now I think I've talked about this
before but if I didn't you guys want to
make sure that you're frequently
checking your challenges page right here
frequently go in and check this page
because
the game will pop up and tell you but
like look right there
there's one that I've completely missed
you see over there on the right it says
claim rewards I had I missed it I didn't
come in here and claim it
so I'm gonna go ahead and claim it now
okay so that one we're good on you want
to make sure that you have the check
mark like right here there's another one
anti-venom that is a gear trait
I think I did do or no I haven't done
the I haven't completed that one yet I
think it's because the the
indicators they're not really clear like
this right here that gold shining I'm
like oh I've unlocked that one no it's
in progress
you had a bunch of just waiting yeah
that's what happened to me the first
time I didn't even realize you're
supposed to go in there and do that I
was probably just ignoring the messages
that were popping up so let's see that
was on Quest let's go over to combat or
no that was combat wasn't it yeah let's
do Quest now okay we got the check mark
check mark
top of the class cloak that looks pretty
cool
Stone necklace 014 we've got seven of
ten on the lucky leprechaun all right
now let's do it for exploration
one out of two on that one
oh haven't claimed that one yet
quidditch Captain's uniform let's go
ahead and claim that
and I think we're caught up now
on that page so you got to go and do it
for every page
okay so whenever it's whenever you get
that little shimmering like that see how
that one just above my cursor there that
means you've got something to go and
unlock it's kind of confusing though
because I see the gold and it's like oh
you can unlock no that's the one that
you're currently progressing toward
to mark that right there
Jenna Lee been watching other people's
stream till yours has downloaded
are you on PC
are you on console
and then we got room of requirement
which looks like oh wow there's only a
few in this one
so we did uh last time
we unlocked the ability to
catch the beasts finally
and we unlock that section of the room
of requirement as well all right but I'm
just going to go straight into my quest
page here we got to start making some
progress we're at level 24 but look at
all these missions we have dude look at
all these missions we have
gotta leave for college hey good luck
now it does kind of when it's over here
it does block more of the
this menu I feel like so I'm just gonna
go straight for this one right here meet
Sebastian in Feld Croft is the next one
see right everybody's passing me up I
can't have that I can't have it
I gotta get caught up
I've been focusing too much on making
videos
hey harry with the with the membership
thank you so much why is it not popping
on the screen
why is it not popping Harry come on
catch up catch up
catch up stream elements
no they're just not gonna do it
they're just not gonna do it I guess
it did earlier though when we first
switched over
all right
any mods who are here anybody hanging
out if I miss memberships let me know I
should still be able to see it because
it pops up as a large
green indicator
you're on the same Quest right now Chris
you did that one too see maybe I've just
been exploring too much that's what we
basically all we did on the uh
on the last stream that's all we did is
just go and explore we were showing
people different parts of the game and
stuff
all right so let's go let's look at the
map I think we have to meet Sebastian
oh he wants us to meet him all the way
out here dude and we don't have oh okay
we're gonna have to do some traveling
then let's go straight to
just go to this one right here
and then we're gonna go in
no Johnny I haven't done any of the
Haunted Hogs mean stuff
is it accessible like from the beginning
oh you're looking for more Demi guys
yeah those are gonna be pretty useful I
can tell
now here's something I just learned
about the broom recently
if you
are holding down the right trigger to
make to give yourself that little speed
boost it's the broom kind of has like
two speed boosts there's R2
which is kind of like you can use that
as much as you want then L2 is that
yellow
even faster speed boost
if you get tired of holding down R2
you actually can just click the left
stick
so I just I just clicked it right there
and now
oops
it actually makes my control a little
bit worse for some reason when I do that
but
if you get tired of holding down the
right trigger you can do that and the
way that I figured that out was
by
let me go ahead and stop it here if you
do the if you hit right on the d-pad
you'll see the extra broom controls
there so L2 speed burst R2 hold for
flight speed whereas L3 will toggle the
flight speed dream and plays with the
Super Chat thank you so much dreaming
absolutely loving this game uh jump
straight in had been lost since a young
Slytherin just learned crucio earlier
been spamming it since
Bellatrix who
yeah I haven't seen I haven't even seen
the unforgivables yet
haven't even seen them
Ah that's up to you Leah we're just kind
of we're just kind of playing so I'm
just playing through this place my story
where I'm at
so if you don't want to know anything
then it's it's probably safer
oh man
it's my first time being in this area
okay before we go and access the mission
though I want to unlock this right here
yeah I'm on PS5 yep
I am on PS5
it's like a place right out of a
storybook all right it's it's night time
right now I wonder if we're gonna have
to
maybe Sebastian shows up in the day
yep there he is
listening while playing there you go
there you go all right Sebastian what's
up dude enjoying the view keeping an eye
on things
feldcroft isn't what it used to be no
one has felt safe
Castle over there Brookwood Castle my
uncle Solomon is a former Aura and
refuses to look into it even after Anne
was cursed by one of them possibly
demons
I heard a goblin refer to wizard kind as
wand carriers
a new friend from Hogwarts will help
lift her spirits
bring back the Anna I Used to Know come
on
Mission gotcha
this way
yeah I have no idea I'm
clearly I need to play a lot more of the
game
clearly Cloudcroft used to be a lot
livelier oops didn't mean to go the fan
Rock slots wandering about all the time
everyone stays out of sight
all right Sebastian let's go
one thing I want to do before my sister
should be Justin's oh dude this might be
the crucial Quest actually
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
make a save right here
because if I need to go back and make
some additional content of me actually
learning the curses because I don't I
don't want to learn them
all right I'm going to save over this
third save right here
dreaming with another Super Chat not far
from seeing them Sev gloves uh oh okay
well I was thinking like we're about to
meet a sister and we'd already seen that
preview
of that that Quest they showed us that
much so
this cutscene is so good oh Missy dude
everybody's ahead of me now
everybody's ahead
I do not know max level yeah I
I don't want to know I just want to
experience I mean the rumor before the
game launched was 40 but I don't know if
that's been confirmed Sebastian where
did you
is I think you recognize that triple fix
cannot reverse a curse
nothing can
the sooner you accept that reality the
better dude
but we haven't tried everything there is
no
when will you accept that never
I can never accept it
what you've done oh no I'm sorry
oh you're blaming him
what
oh come on man
[Music]
um
welcome to the new Subs guys thank you
if you don't mind that was messed up
that was not Sebastian's fault at all
not the visit he died before
I think I'm gonna take off the mask too
like I don't really I'm not loving the
mask
I'm not loving it
it's not bad but
I've had the mask on long enough
let's go without it for a bit
oh wait don't wait though we could go
with the half moon
because I think I do have those unlocked
this young kid looking like he's trying
to be Merlin
all right nah take to take them off
there
no Lorena that's what somebody else was
just asking I have not
right thank you for becoming a member
welcome to house wrecking tour
yeah I'm level 24 almost to 25.
all right he said he needed a moment
alone
that boy will Fray my last nerve Solomon
come on dude you were just like you
freaked out Mr Silo oh yes Sebastian's
friend I apologize on behalf of my
nephew he be half of your nephew he
thinks he can help Anne but dude you're
the one he's the one who freaked out
surely there's something you've not yet
discovered the kill
yeah I feel better than the healers some
Mongols perhaps the healers don't know
everything so Sebastian is
single-mindedly focused on finding a way
to help it dude you've seen what I can
do with ancient Magic
have you seen that your faith in
Sebastian has misplaced some sort of
dark magic cursed Anne and the Goblins
aren't likely to explain themselves
anytime soon giving her hope is cry like
that take it off now is keep
uncomfortable and stay out of the
loyalist way
I don't know man like I kind of get
where he's coming from but I feel like
he's just coming in way too hard with
this like
I'm gonna say hulk be a good with all
due respect sir hope could keep and
Spirits I think he needs to hear this
but I know what's best for Anne and
daily nerd what's up dude Brothers
children you already got it how so how
do you uh if you really want to be you
have to be so far in the game sure
Sebastian does what he should do not
what he wants to do oh he's no idea the
harm he could do if he doesn't stop
uh
oh don't put me in that position
Solomon dude you're
I'm not loving Solomon not loving him
not loving this guy
so for the Merlin yeah a lot of people
were having trouble with the Merlin
cloak um who asked that teebs yeah a lot
of people just didn't get the Merlin it
wasn't progressing for them but they're
going to be doing another live stream on
Friday Avalanche is so they said they're
gonna be doing it then so that'll be
your next chance to go for it oh I heard
I heard the thing
oh this is another area where you can
train
why can't he do both yeah pops up a
quest after third trial ah gotcha beat
the main dude I'm telling you
everybody's passed me up
man I've been streaming making too many
videos and doing too many streams I've
just gotten completely passed up
practice dummies residents of fail crops
sometimes use these to practice their
spell casting especially in light of
recent Goblin attacks okay this is kind
of cool
I keep hoping that we're gonna get like
another crossed once but that was one
thing I was a little disappointed by it
was so short like cross wands was just
over revelio
and then that was it I haven't seen
anything else about it
oh am I gonna get to go back in there
and talk to Anne see if we can no level
two darn it
oh I heard it again
sounds like it's this way
not gonna be here for long wanted your
take on people spoiling the games ending
on Twitter
these people are always trying to ruin
ruin other people's fun
people always I mean it's like
happens with everything
but the reason this one's happening yeah
it it's even more unfortunate
the Feld Croft way well uh the well and
felt Croft ran dry some 400 years ago
during a great drought sadly many perish
as a result including at least one young
boy whose father refused to speak for
years thereafter Legend says that all
was saved when a group of benevolent
witches and wizards used a never before
seen powerful magic to restore water to
the region oh that's the thing we learn
about the ancient Magic
[Music]
you love it Brent yeah I'm loving it so
far too
uh yeah Alva you can yeah yeah they they
have an FAQ up
as long as you follow those steps you
can get the game even if you're gonna be
playing later even if you're going to be
playing on a different platform like PS4
or Xbox One or even switch
they have a full FAQ that kind of
Explains It All
upgraded the roll yet oh yeah this
yeah Sonic the Hedgehog
I agree Lorena I wish crossbones was
permanent
I'm sorry about earlier those bouts of
pain yeah let's hear what she wants
anybody gonna like anybody gonna take
her thoughts into account can I talk to
her like let's do you want to look for a
cure Anne where do you stand on this
I didn't there we go let's get it there
we go truly
all right
not anyone's fault
not anyone's of course she's just gonna
be super nice by the way you must be the
new fifth year Sebastian told me about I
am Sebastian and I met during a rather
Lively duel in defense against the dark
arts oh dear Professor I am playing on
normal but I've been thinking about
bumping it up too hard and she knows how
to keep students like my brother
and me because it's like it's not been a
huge challenge for me so far there are
moments
goblins
that come with Sebastian whenever he's
home all right come on I want to ask her
more questions
Sebastian mentioned something about your
uncle being an exorer but refusing to go
after ran Rock's loyalists I must say I
wasn't prepared for him I haven't passed
you up Elizabeth Uncle Solomon is that's
frustrating I got a job I got a family
how's everybody doing this let's break
it so far and I had the game early mean
well I know they do but my uncle is
right his curse cannot be undone
feel it Sebastian cannot take away my
pain oh perhaps you can help him to
understand that that's not what I was
wanting you to say
darn it
okay like those are her wishes then I'm
I will try to stop him then
I will try to stop him I'll do my best
I can promise to speak with him about it
if that's what she wants to search for a
cure was futile I'm afraid I'm getting
tired I should probably rest
thank you for stopping by
gives you a challenge even without the
bosses I ought to see how Sebastian's
faring
somebody said what I think about the
game oh I'm loving it Brody I'm loving
it
oh dude we can read the letter your Ann
Hogwarts isn't the same without you well
sharp is still as foul but you know what
I mean I hope you're feeling better
Sebastian
oh dude
and I need an apple I need an apple
before we go and do this
Sebastian this is my potion kit not your
sleep
all right well we're gonna have to
Tell Sebastian this is not what Anne
wants
not what Anne wants
yeah I'm going I'm going good
going good
why will he not listen to me she's my
sister have you asked her what she wants
Sebastian Sebastian you got a first-hand
glance of what I'm dealing Uncle yeah
he's a jerk apologize for I'm with you
oh he was out of line
but after just talking to her
you know what he was out of line I'll
admit I wasn't expecting him to be so
angry he was he's always angry
he's been angry since my parents died
after Anne was hurt he only grew worse
similar situation that's me somehow oh
he's calling me my Father's son as if
that's an insult I'm the one trying to
help her he's simply given up both Anne
and your uncle seem genuinely convinced
that nothing more can be done for her I
refuse to believe that Anne's pain is
more than physical it has changed her
entirely I think so my sister I think so
and I'm going to get her back oh me I
need to show you where it happened
Round Rock's loyalists are capable of
much more than people realize they
should not be underestimated let's go
all the debris you'll see is from
whatever's going on at that abandoned
estate
they've been digging for something now
people can play 15 hours a day
print I know man
I know dude up there on that Plateau
somebody commented on my uh
sorry just trying to try not to talk
over them too much somebody commented on
my first impressions video because I got
the game early thanks to WB they
provided me with an early copy
Sebastian what are you doing
Sebastian bro
we could have went stealth right there
foreign
just two
all right I guess Sebastian nope I heard
another one
but yeah somebody commented on my first
impressions video
and was like dude how have you only
played 20 hours
I'm like man I have two kids
I have a wife I have a full-time job and
I make videos on YouTube
um I'm sorry if I could drop everything
and no life this game
now if I had known what I know now like
if I had known that we were going to be
getting the game early I would have
requested off work last week and then I
could have basically no life
you know kid while the kids are in
school wife's at work like I'm I it'd be
game time
revelio all right Sebastian can we go
stealth now dude can we go stealth or is
he just following me oh wait
where does it want me to go now
Sebastian why aren't you leading me
anywhere
I guess we're just supposed to take out
these goblins over here
sleep on my face off work for two weeks
that was a good call that was a good
call
yeah I think so too
I think so too Brian I think it's one of
the better cloaks
and I don't even normally love like The
Color Purple for a tire and stuff but
yeah this one's nice all right Sebastian
are you actually are you with me on this
okay good we're both all right
all right disillusionment
disillusionment who is seeing me
that guy's turned around
you know what let me see if I have a
talent point
if I have a talent point I'm just gonna
put it right into stealth
oh darn it I don't you see I haven't
upgraded Stealth at all but I went I
went all on the core all on the core
spells
Jake what's up Jake you finally got it
working
nice are you making good progress
you already got the Broom the broom
takes a little bit so that's good
progress
Ive
nothing you don't see anybody you don't
know anything
all right can we use like the bush for a
little cover here
ravennial
oh there's a bunch of them
it's okay we're gonna be able to take
out a couple
nope you still don't see me
you don't see me Sebastian you could
help you know like
he's just not even bothering
oh they're investigating they're
investigating now
that one's just spinning spinning in
circles all right no don't turn around
you're dead
that's kind of like my go-to combo right
now
levioso accio incendio
I need to get better at switching to the
other spells
oh that one almost got me
also
[Music]
Stupify so powerful
oh it got blocks right there
is that it
oh there's more
dude
my timing's off tonight
there we go
[Music]
all right he's got a gold one
let's finish him off with the ancient
Magic
yeah exactly exactly you look for the
l1r1
and then you know you got it yep
all right so see it does pop up and say
you have uncollected rewards but man
it's it goes quick
it goes quick
all right so let's go in here we need to
go to our challenges looks like it's a
combat one
right there Goblin resistance
all right nice
oh does the ray tracing look pretty good
I haven't played around with it too much
on which actually I don't even know if
it's
if it's technically in the console one
yet or not because originally they said
it was part of the day one patch but it
does look like it's
it gives you the option I haven't really
experienced anything with it though to
see if it works or not
all right so
those loyalists deserved what they got
couldn't agree more
this is where it happened we smelt smoke
in the middle of the night see what
happens with the same spell more than
once shooting from the estate it just
lets you the times I've done it it'll
put it on multiple spots worried someone
would be hurt
she came face to face with a horde of
goblins frantically trying to Stamp Out
the Flames suddenly an icy voice drifted
out from somewhere in the smoke
children should be seen and not heard a
blinding blast followed they didn't even
give her a chance to run children's have
seen and not heard
someone has said that
or maybe it was in a TV show I was
watching I feel like someone has said
that in this game
uh they were trying to hide something
they'll kill for no reason
totally violent response to a child
wandering by
what were they trying to hide my
thoughts exactly we could test that out
it may be grasping at Billy wigs but I
keep thinking that there might be
something here that could lead me to
whoever kirstan might be the only way to
learn what type of magic harmed her
which could help me find a cure perhaps
you're right
the Loyalists are everywhere but they do
seem to be spending a lot of time here
and it's likely they're hiding something
and at Rookwood Castle shall we have a
look around
they seem to have set up camp here for a
specific reason The Rookwood castle for
everything
hmm
all right let's try what Ellen was
saying right there if we do uh
I bet it'll be a cool down for
for both okay like let's say we put
incendio on both
yeah they both they both just match
it was a good thought it was a good
thought
so here's kind of how I have things
mapped right now this is kind of like my
utility
then on the right that's room of
requirement stuff and then on the left
we've got damage and then also glacias
but
so I'm still not using I don't have I
don't have descendo equipped anywhere
and I don't have
another one I don't have a Resto
momentum equipped anywhere
so I'm not even really getting to use
those I feel like I should if you're not
in the room of requirement it's like
what's the point let's go this and this
and then we could kind of I don't know
maybe add defendo later
yeah shares the cooldown
one thing you wish was an option was the
Dodge block indicator from easy mode
oh is there is there like a different
Dodge and block on easy mode
all right where do you want me to go
Sebastian said something about a castle
oh is it down here
hold on first I want to see
oh yeah I think we're going in there
let's see what this is over here
always armed and ready for a fight run
Rock's loyalists oh is that it
think a Resto momentum would have
completed one of those dueling Feats oh
maybe so maybe so
I've heard Goblin dicks sites like these
are popping up everything
it's a wonder the ministry isn't doing
more hmm
all right Rebellion
why is he like crouched down like that
are we supposed to be sneaking around
oh we got something here
whose home was that
was that bit abandoned long since I've
lived here
was a Hogwarts Professor lived here once
centuries ago oh interesting Skye
interesting it might be worth taking a
closer look at the house itself
well then why are you not coming with me
dude why are you
why are you just lingering about back
there
you know what I wish you could do I wish
you could Crouch without having to cast
revellio
there's not a way to do that right no
anything in here this well looks
familiar I knew it I knew there'd be
something by the well
Sebastian
I've seen this before
this house the well the view what do you
mean when give me a moment I'll explain
in a second
let's wait in a second why can't you
explain right now
all right looks like we got one more
thing to investigate here
and it's inside
oh Sebastian
face has been like burned away but this
was damaged by the fire the night that
Anne was cursed
could be
but it looks to me as though this was
intentional yeah I think so too
and then like this area was burned away
too
the pulso the pickaxe into the wood
oh back at that other spot Maybe
okay that's definitely what
couldn't Pringles
okay I can lock onto it why is that not
no
let's try
no that's weird
fly through the streets of hogsmeade
yeah there's like that little barrier
oh dude there is something over there
why can we not destroy that
I keep feeling like bombarda is required
to get past something
confringo isn't that where you go yeah
it's what I tried
foreign
wow that's weird
it's confringo yeah that's what I'm
trying all right I tried that and other
things maybe like throw it in a
different kind of spot
that is really weird
The Vanishing
no way the one that I just unequipped
wait Rye says look outside first okay
okay
hey what's up Mac how's it going
oh we gotta do another story part first
oh and there's more money in here
hmm
all right I'm not seeing anything that
we haven't
unless we're supposed to fly up there
I'm seeing some blue up there but I
don't think that's it
I was like if that works
crazy yeah I don't think you can go in
there
oh you just need to talk to him
so you guys are throwing me off
I'm like wait there's something I'm
missing out here
it's like wise can fringo not working on
this house did belong to a Hogwarts
Professor hundreds of years ago who what
do you I found offensive that day in the
Restricted Section with a memory that
showed this house now we're telling him
everything okay and a drought the
keepers have shown other memories as
well
the gull became a Hogwarts professor her
name evanesco was a good idea though
morganock that's a good idea she was one
of the keepers oh you think that's her
in the picture why can quidditch and you
found a pensive in the library
I'm not following you I realize it's a
lot to take in I'm not even sure I
understand it all yet
not like quidditch they call themselves
Keepers because they're protecting some
type of knowledge
it has to do with the Vault Gringotts
let me see 12. you have ran Rock and
Rookwood after you because of something
you found at Gringotts where you ended
up via report key and now you've been
witnessing memories left by keepers oh
and this house belonged to a Hogwarts
Professor who was one of them yeah we've
been keeping some Secrets Seb if I
didn't know you I think you were pulling
my leg it is all a bit much isn't it
when you put it like that
the point is we both have good reason to
search this house
you for answers about what happened yep
yep yeah and Me For answers about the
keepers
all right look at this
dude Skye I totally agree yeah for a
reason there is it blocking something oh
wait and now guys confringo
magically look at that I can't believe
it
all right
um but yeah there are so many references
to quidditch and like the fact you
you play it it's kind of funny actually
worth a closer look when they've left
all of this simply strewn about
tells me they're after something bigger
when black first announced it he's like
he says something about like at least
you can still fly it's like dude they
totally put that in there wait I'm dying
what in the world oh these things lumos
mercallius what's up dude I know the
Metroid Prime announcement
oh
so pumped
that's one of my favorite games of all
time guys if you didn't see just before
the um
we got a couple letters in here
I think I read them out of order
it is my second week in the camp more
arrive each day the Muggle doctors and
even some of our own healers are doing
all that they can for them the grief is
palpable the ones who have survived the
plague are forever damaged by their loss
a fever may pass the skin May mend and
Scar but the devastating SAR remains
so I mean much like my father who had
lost a child I couldn't bear it I longed
to give him some shred of relief I'm
beginning to think that the others are
wrong I have the power to help these
Souls
interesting it seems It's arbitrary not
to help them as it would be to rid them
of their torment a journal entry of his
adoras
I should hold on to this
oh it's it's all good right
it's all good welcome to the new Subs
guys welcome okay so that's two of seven
I wonder if we can we I don't think we
can evidence go those but they look very
similar to the chairs that we were able
to uh
evanesco earlier so I kind of want to
just try it
nope you can't
oh can we just light these torches that
make it easier
incendio
oh come on
light the torch
experience
lumos fine can't light the torch
all right I guess we can only find this
one right now
what's up Craig how's it going
your life savings on Caz I don't I mean
I don't think I would say that
maybe if if that's your life savings
maybe you would want to wait for a price
drop I travel here to learn but I long
to help
my internal struggle is overwhelming
it's as though the magic wants to heal
and I'm the one preventing it from doing
so should I lose hope will I forever
regret not having done more
I cannot look into their eyes knowing
that I could lessen the burden of
Heartache I saw the man leaving camp
today the one who so reminded me of my
father surely it wouldn't hurt to help
him I could further my research of
course but that would be a fortuitous
consequence of doing something good with
this ability seems these journal entries
are from his adora's travels
lumos
you're not going to believe this I can
see the undercroft
what oh no way because that happens to
me too
nah dude we get like this ancient magic
ability
we can see places honestly nothing you
say sounds strange to me anymore he's
already on board now
I can see this hey sounds good Levi have
a good one thanks for stopping by
this has happened before I'm listening I
have a rare ability to see Whispers of
ancient magic I don't know what I was
expecting to say but it wasn't that
wasn't that I
I knew you weren't telling me everything
chin magic fig told us not to but
apparently we don't care entirely sure
but the keepers have said that it's a
powerful magic that should only be
wielded by a select few and you can
wield it I can I don't know
fig and I think I somehow found a way to
harness that Magic's power are you
telling me that goblins may be wielding
some sort of wizard magic that's what
we're trying to find out what I do know
is that my ability allows me to travel
through these windows I see wait
we can get straight to the undercroft
from here
ominous will be flawed we can
but perhaps better there's been a lot of
don't tell anyone in this game
well then invisible secret ancient magic
passageway here we come
I'm tempted to hold my breath how many
hours
so I think the in-game counter is wrong
because I've played way more than what
it says lumos
and
also it's going to be skewed because we
did a stream
Tuesday where all we did was explore
like we just explored because I didn't
want to spoil things for people but now
we're just you know we're just playing
the game now I mean so I would say I'm
probably 25 30 hours somewhere in that
range
I mean at least at least 25 because I
played 20 before
why would the door lead us here before
um look
16 hours nice
yeah take your time guys
take your time enjoy it
I'm I'm like blown away at how fast
people are
making it through the game something's
missing
a note
let's have a look
all right we got an ancient magic symbol
another ancient magic symbol
and that's really all I can make out on
it maybe some ancient runes or something
there helpful in the notes
not really no revelio
I guess we just talked to him again
and tell him no symbol I've seen similar
symbols used by the keepers I've been
thinking
keeper lived in that house centuries ago
and ran Rock in his lot had been
searching there you said that goblins
may be wielding a haunted couple magic
thanks for the sub do you think Anne was
cursed by ancient magic I can't be sure
of course but I don't think so
I didn't see any traces of it around
your sister hmm
very well oh dude he looks suspicious of
us ancient magic he looks so suspicious
you know about it true
perhaps this triptych will lead us to
answers then we'll have to unravel what
this all means
but now I need to see ominous don't
worry I won't tell him anything there's
too many secrets in this game Salazar
Slytherin had a secret scriptorium here
in Hogwarts you did not
sounds worth looking into any idea where
in the castle no idea ominous just
learned of it I'll let you know what I
find out oh my God goodness
unfold into all of this
heads and that's a mess
but I'm glad you told me everything oh
we told you a lot didn't we
I'll be in touch
till then oh that's it that's the end of
it
my favorite area of the castle oh that's
tough
I mean the common room's great
but um nightly nerd I don't know if
nightly nerd's still here I was watching
his video
today
and he's right like the common rooms you
don't really
go I've got to them a lot
oh my goodness
oh my goodness Andrew has returned
ladies and gentlemen
Andrew has returned
with a 200 dollar Super Chat
last time Andrew Was Here YouTube hit
him with a an apparent limit on how much
could be donated
Andrew says told you I plan to donate
more for show I guess the wand
customization and now I'm not held back
by the donation cap that YouTube has
oh my goodness Andrew dude
I don't know what to say man thank you
so much
I'm glad you're glad you came back
glad you came back anything you want me
to show off tonight we we showed one
customization last time
obviously you probably have the game on
your own now
all that money Andrew must be selling
eggs
appreciate all the hard work oh my
goodness yeah it's been a blast Andrew
I've I've had a blast covering this game
but
I was telling the chat earlier it's like
everybody's passing me up now I've gotta
I've been wasting too much well not
wasting too much time but I've been
spending so much time making videos and
stuff that
I've got to uh I've got to actually get
back to playing the game again
gotta get back to playing the game Mrs
reckon tour in the chat thanking Andrew
[Music]
yeah I was talking to Mrs raconteur
about that donation the other night and
she said she looked at it and thought
she's like why is the chat freaking out
it says 3.99 you know like we appreciate
the 3.99
no there's there's a there's there's a
decimal 399 decimal nine nine
and then tonight with the 199.99
and then Elwyn with five more gifteds
she's oh what's trying to get Andrew a
gifted membership
oh YouTube really needs to add that
feature where you can choose who gets
the gift
you're a wizard Harry all right welcome
to all the new members Elwyn thank you
for the five gifted looks like we got
Craig with that Skye got one of the
gifteds Elizabeth Kmart and Geek Squad
got one of the gifteds
congratulations guys enjoy your emotes
at least for mods yeah like that's the
thing on Twitch where you can I mean you
can choose a specific person
if you want to gift somebody
Owens I was thinking we've got to make
Andrew must become a member here
all right guys so we just finished that
little section with Seb right there
and now we need to go to back to our oh
wait we completed another challenge
though
combat challenge
and where is it
okay wait what am I what am I missing
it said we had it's it said we had a
combat one right okay we got check mark
there check mark there
that one we're only at one of 70. we
can't get that one yet check mark
okay that was weird
that was really weird maybe we just made
pro I don't know
I don't know why that popped up right
there
do we have a goal I want to accomplish
Johnny I want to complete as many story
quests as I can that's my goal
that's my goal
so we've got
um
oh yeah yeah Ellen's trying to find out
Andrew do you have the options yeah so I
think to be able to receive gifted
memberships there's like an option you
have to turn on
all right so this one's level 16
Professor Shaw's class is at the top of
the astronomy Tower upstairs from the
entrance to the room of requirement I
should head there now
acquired little 16 or Natty is waiting
for me near a castle ruined oh that
sounds cool I want to do that one we
have to have wingardium for it that's
fine
all right let's do that one next let's
go to the map
oh it is way over here
and there's a couple spots we do not
have unlocked
along the way
all right so I think the nearest fast
travel point
I mean at least let's get outside I
really don't mind the travel in this
game
let's just get outside and then we'll
hop on the Broom
you can't imagine how inconvenient
travel was before I invented
let's see is it marked yeah there we go
foreign
TV fishy thank you glad you enjoy the
videos appreciate that
and then my favorite event
wait what is your favorite event on
either Harry Potter or Hogwarts Legacy
oh I'm well see I haven't beaten
Hogwarts Legacy yet
or he asked me to like between the two
or of each one
because my favorite event I mean for for
Potter has got to be like just the whole
lead up to book seven
the whole lead up to book seven and then
finally getting it and it just being an
incredible credible book was awesome
don't think you do using your phone to
watch still working don't have access to
all the standard YouTube functions ah
Andrew
there might be a way we've been I know
the moderators have been trying to
figure that out it's like sometimes
gifted options show up on
mobile or they do for some people and
they don't for other I don't know it's
yeah it's weird how mobile is it's just
like it's very different
that's a good question Lorena that's a
good question
all right dude why is my
my monitor keeps flickering and I'm
watching on the stream it's not doing it
you guys aren't seeing it but on my end
I don't know why it keeps doing that all
right we can't enter this area while
mounted so
yeah I don't think there is anywhere to
see all of the
combat combos I mean if they did have it
I feel like of all the places
collections Maybe
because you don't have any
I mean you do have your traits here
and then if you go into your spells
think you just oh he thinks he just
turned it on
Ellen's gonna try to keep gifting
you don't have to do that Elwyn you do
not have to do that
all right so if we go into the spell
menu here
yeah like if you hover it shows oh my
gosh there it goes she just did it again
five more gifteds and Andrew got it
oh my goodness he was the first name
let's go
wow
Elwyn thank you for the five gifted we
got Andrew with that Brody Nat Knight
namaze and then Spike deagle
oh it's just got a gift of membership
folks enjoy the emotes you also get a
special role in our Discord if you're a
Discord person uh and discounts on merch
and you also get a special little uh
badge by your name whenever you post on
YouTube on my channel whether it's in
the chat or whether it's uh
on one of our videos that we share
all right Natty let's do this over here
yeah you're a wizard Harry oh your
fellow Gryffindor Andrew we need to stay
let's go dude let's go
why are we all the way out here as
promised
to fight Hollows up to
I noticed him reading a letter all I
could see was that it was signed by and
bore the Seal of Victor Rookwood and
one other thing
hello mentioned you to his colleagues
they did not mistake you for someone
else dude we're having to come clean
with all our friends now Rockwood and
Harlow are after me why did he lie to me
I didn't know what I went with a
Hogwarts student Professor fake told me
to keep things quiet right I know I can
trust you Natty dude don't save anything
and I found a Gringotts when were you at
Grim gots just before I came to Hogwarts
and in fact it's why I was late to the
Sorting ceremony a portkey brought us
there after the dragon attacked our
Carriage what on Earth there's one more
thing
odd if I'm
if I'm fake says I have a rare
connection to a powerful form of ancient
magic is that the magic you used for oh
don't feel bad Sky I think so I'm still
learning but I can see traces of it and
I've cast magic I can't otherwise
explain I know it's a lot to take in
it is oh we're coming cleaned it and I
will have more questions
for now it's safe to say that Rookwood
and Hollow are a threat to both of us to
all of us and we can help to take them
down for good I haven't really had many
questions
this is why I followed Hollow here and
why I wrote to you I need your help to
retrieve it
oh okay let's see what are your reasons
for going after Rookwood and Harlow
as a singer and go directly to the
ministry do you think they will listen
to a student I'm loving it fishy that's
an investigation the ministry will come
in later
yeah what what Ginny said what Ginny
said Skye exactly
what are your reasons for going after
real quick you seem to be very
determined in stopping Rookwood and
Harlow
why I knew men like him in Uganda
I know how bad things can get if they
are not stopped it's their loss yeah she
told us about it before share when we
have more time for now let's do what we
came to do
uh well then let's hope you find the
letter Natty I'm glad oh this might be
the mission that we've seen
I think it is from the Autodesk
I do not see any guts yes we should
still try to be as quiet as possible
exactly Apollo is here after all
Felipe exactly
yeah this is also the one they showed at
the Autodesk presentation
oh yeah this is definitely it it's
definitely it revelio
this charm is stronger than what do we
have here they do not want anyone
getting you gate Duty no one enters
[Music]
okay
nothing super important in that can we
just hop on our broom oh no we had to we
had to uh
Dismount when we entered the area
all right oh got some ash Winder eggs
oh you you had your doubts and you you
got it based off my uh Impressions video
nice I hope you enjoy it I mean I'm
having a blast so far I I knew
I wonder what that does the old Potter
games I mean some of them had had some
charm but a lot of them were rough and
yet I still enjoyed them so I knew I was
going to enjoy this game even if it was
just like halfway decent but the fact
that it's just been
almost a universally praised game makes
it even better
yeah I don't know if I'd like that or
not like once you guys learn Wingardium
Leviosa
if you cast accio on it hold on and you
keep holding it it like kind of does
this Auto transition
I mean I guess that's kind of nice
because you don't have to have both
spells equipped
but if I guess if you just let go yeah
then it's just like a normal accio
all right what do we have up there more
coins
KSI welcome how's it going
scaling crazy places to get bags oh I I
just I read that somewhere today
I can't remember where it was it was
either on Reddit or on Twitter or
somewhere I've been reading so much
about this game watching so many videos
reading about it but yeah I saw that um
someone was like yeah I didn't know you
could
you could just accio
the loose loot bags
which is pretty cool can we make that
jump
oh come on
oh my goodness you guys this my monitor
I hope my monitor's not going bad
or something with my capture card it
keeps flickering on my end it's very
annoying
just glad it's not doing it on the
stream but if I just randomly stop
that's why
all right there's gotta be something
we're missing here can we win Guardian
wallets underneath
revelio
oh we need another one
okay that's too far I don't think it's
anything to do with that
where did Natty go by the way
she just gone
noted for the next time you play Trisha
nice
yeah my so my next video I was scripting
it out today it's 90 scripted out I'm
gonna finish that and probably record it
tonight and hopefully release it
tomorrow but it's like 10
basically 10 essential early game tips
for Hogwarts Legacy
because there's a lot of stuff that
which I kind of like that the game
doesn't
spell out every single thing for you
there's a lot to discover on your own
turning off the Monitor and turn it back
on yeah I might try that too yeah
because so we can levitate that
wait a second and then can I jump on oh
you can let's go okay so I was I was
almost there but I was standing on top
of it
oh yeah you guys were saying levioso
yeah yeah that was it all right I'm
gonna try this I'm gonna try turning off
the monitor
let's see if I can reach it without
having to
no not exit
if the stream dies it's all your fault
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
all right power ain't back up now
all right well it completely moved all
my screens
all right hopefully that worked if it
did thank you for the tip hopefully it
worked
same way with Star Wars Jedi Fallen
order
hey thank you Rye I appreciate it yeah
that's the cool thing about we're kind
of testing out both YouTube and twitch
for our gameplay streams right now
which we've been having great success on
both tomorrow we're going to be on
Twitch it just cut out again darn it
that was a good idea though
is a good idea I'll have to troubleshoot
it after
the stream tonight
I might actually be even worse though
but um one of the nice things about
YouTube is the fact that
like the VOD just stays up there so
you can always go over to the live Tab
and watch it anytime oh I bet we're
gonna have to interact with something
through here
yep there it is
the Tulsa
and that should be enough
come on get in there
and let's see do a depulso oh we can't
cast from this position
wait why not
why not
all right I guess we can just move that
from the other I thought you could
cast from here it's just not letting me
when I'm in when I'm underneath right
here okay
monitor demon this time right dude I am
just
we have been streaming every Tuesday for
I don't know six months or so
and I could probably count on one hand
the number of
technical issues we've had in that six
months
then this game comes out and it's just
been left and right we've had streaming
issues
left and right
there was a uh like an update for my
capture card I wonder if it's not
something to do with that
see I don't think it's OBS yeah my CPU
is barely even getting used
barely getting used that looks as if it
might raise the gate
all right we already did that from the
outside
and we'll do it again and then we got an
accio
there we go
I knew you could do it this way I will
get the duel
oh I almost missed that
can't believe I have to write this down
but you Moon mines
don't listen push the gate open Don't
blast it if I find it blown to Pieces
again I swear it'll be the end of you
lot
all right
oh and there's a ladder that goes down
I don't think this is the way we're
supposed to go I just want to fully
explore
hey it's all good fishy it was a good
thought it was a good thought
oh that's an upgrade
what is that over there caution centaurs
can I get through here
no
hmm
all right I think we're supposed to go
back up though oh wait before I do that
let me go ahead and upgrade
let us upgrade to that new gear piece
that we got
because yeah that's gonna up us to
yeah UPS Us by two not not crazy but
I'll take it
I will take it and then we'll go ahead
and apply we'll keep rocking the Merlin
robes
and maybe we have an upgrade here too
nope all of those are lower
seven gear slots open right now
did get a new hat as well okay none of
those are upgraded
oh we unlocked a new one
foreign
oh that's the underneath never mind
never mind
oh no I forgot what I had it on
it was something with like brown boots
not that light of a brown though
no I'm not gonna be able to find it
again
wait it might have just been that
actually yeah
oh no I remember which one it was it was
this Crimson one yep
what was my reaction on Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets when Ron opens
the howler
in the movie
I mean pretty embarrassing right
run old Weasley
how many hours you've been playing
Hogwarts Legacy oh man I mean I'm over
I'm nowhere near as much as some people
I can tell you that
I've gotten passed up even though I got
the game early
we did unlock a new Talent point though
nice I'm not gonna spend it yet because
I kind of want to wait
I've fully upgraded this one I feel like
I'm just gonna go all the way on these
two
makes sense
yeah
and then because I I mean these are the
things that I'm using most of all
yeah at least 25 hours if not 30 hours
fishy is probably if I had to put an
hour amount on it
some of these students the attitude
right elwin yeah
yep some of them uh do not have the best
attitude and when you meet Sebastian's
Uncle yeah not the best attitude either
but apparently there's a lot of history
there they've been going at it for a
while
that is the main keeper all right sorry
Natalie we had to do some exploring
hello and the letter inside
we'll need to be careful once we get
them this is that exact Mission Yep this
is it we've seen this scene
yeah
High wing
I think Talent points are based on
levels we'll see if I'm level 25 now
because if I am that type of grief
I think you get one every time you level
up
and evidence
and it will actually calculate when you
first unlock talents it'll go back to
all the ones that you've unlocked
there's got to be another way to get up
to the roof somewhere horsey yes indeed
retro Elite at work wish I was at home
because I'd be playing right now well
hey now that is the cool thing about
streams right if you have some down time
at work or something and you can't play
yeah so we leveled up to 25 so that's
when we got that Talent Point yep last
Marauder what's up dude
welcome man thank you for stopping by
oh dude I'm enjoying it so much she
stays out of trouble enjoying it so much
but apparently I'm just way behind
everyone at this point
I'm way behind everyone
I've been worried about making too many
videos I guess and not playing enough
how about you dude how about you
and then how did your uh charity stream
go by the way guys last Marauder if
you're not uh
not familiar another Hogwarts Legacy
content creator
all around good guy also a dad like me
all right so let's I don't even know if
we're supposed to move this or not
oh I hope we were
I hope we were
start starts collecting at five oh
interesting so not not like from
number one number two not straight away
all right so that knocked it down there
okay yeah pretty sure that's what we
were supposed to do
I'm sure we're not missing anything here
how do we get in there
and we're getting close to some enemies
it looks like
okay this is where we just came up
though right yeah okay we're still
working our way up
killing curse and you don't know how to
act
I don't think I'm gonna learn it but I
can't I can't lie dude playing around in
the dark arts Arena
they're just so powerful man
they're so powerful
Wingardium Leviosa
love yourself
all right I'm not the safest place why
did he not grab on
there he goes oh oh shoot shoot
level 25 yeah I just hit Level 25. I
said my traps but apparently like I
don't know on our Tuesday stream I was
just doing all exploration stuff just
showing people around
or no on our Monday Monday stream
because today is dude I don't even know
what day it is Wednesday right yeah it's
Wednesday it's Wednesday
still ahead of you Trisha
yeah see a lot of people had planned
like time off work and everything to
play this game
which so did I I really don't know how I
got behind
and I even
eat the game early and still got behind
yesterday's stream was basically all
about telling people how the drops work
that was what probably two hours of our
four or five hour stream was explaining
drops
oh yeah this is a great place for
stealth right here what the heck how do
you know I'm here you should not
have to teach someone a lesson no no no
I don't think so poacher duelist
I don't think so
do you actually know I'm here freeze a
poacher stalker when they are readying
their attack all right fine I'll show
I'll just I'll reveal myself here
I don't think they actually see me now
they will though I thought you had me
there oh no
all right get ready attack me oh
I'm just focused on her right now
darn it
no my monitor cut out the worst time
dude
it's
funny
you will where's the other one I hear
them
Ultra tracker
they fall off or something
where wait where did they
is it one above me
whoa this is so weird
where did they go
all right well
oh no it won't let me do it because it
still thinks I'm in combat oh there he
is what the heck
he was invisible
goodness that was crazy
could not find him
Hermione Granger in the chat
hello Hermione welcome 25 is high for
this point that's amazing live stream
went so well nice because you went yeah
you went 24 hours
the site went down oh dude that's
unfortunate well hey that's a great
thing you were doing I wish I could have
stopped by
alohomora
wish I would have been able to stop by
there it is right there
there's that one
got it
a graphics card I have for sheet oh so
I'm playing on a PS5 but I'm streaming
from my uh my PC
it's a 2060 super that's what I have
so yeah all it's all it's having to do
is worry about the game
been streaming loads trying to get to
the story did the opposite uh see yeah
I should have I guess I was doing more
side stuff than doing story stuff
but yeah tonight that's why I was like
I'm just gonna start plowing through
story Quest that's what we're gonna be
doing
story Quest story Quest story Quest
knocking them out
all right so is there anything else we
can get in here
let me open this door okay that's just
leading us back out to where we were
all right
so I think we're supposed to go up here
now
I hope Nazi's having an easier time of
it
you played for 26 hours Craig
oh my gosh dude maybe it's my I'm like
I'm an old man now I I don't think I
could go that long
26 hour gaming session
what
will to lock
revelio
all right we can go up here though
yeah like sometimes it's fine like right
now it's not doing anything but then
just randomly the monitor will start
flickering out of nowhere and it hasn't
been doing that I'm telling you if for
any of you guys who have been watching
me for a while
we haven't had issues in a long time and
then as soon as this game comes out
last stream we fired up we were going to
be streaming on OBS and we had no I
couldn't hear the game audio so I had to
stream
from a different from stream labs
but then that one started having uh that
one had different problems
24 hours and you can't move your neck oh
I can't imagine dude
one of the best purchases I made last
year I saved up and I finally got a sit
stand desk
which I say that as I'm sitting right
now
but um
it's really nice because like if I'm if
I'm working a long day and then I need
to and I'm doing some video editing you
could just go back and forth like I
never stick with it in one spot but
having that flexibility to be able to
switch is really nice you're going home
in a way we got a pusher Ranger here
launched
oh my goodness that's such a cool one
right there
just launched them they're right off the
side
oh it's great toy breaker I love it
what was my house Quest like Aloha Mora
oh I guess those are house quests that
I'm doing oops I didn't mean to do that
first thing I like to do is check and
see if
like just go up down left right right
away and see if that works before I
start turning it
sometimes it does
oh they're both like in the same
direction
so yeah the only house Quest I've done
so far I think I've done two with
uh Weasley Garrett's I think is his name
see I didn't know that was a house Quest
though I thought
oh that's interesting
let's see
do I have anything for Weasley
it might be this one
or maybe more unlock after a certain
point in the story I'm not sure
I'm not sure now I'm intrigued
I think you're older than me retro
you're 40. oh my goodness Craig
not oh my goodness that you're 40 but oh
my goodness that you're that age and
doing a 26 hour sesh
that's impressive dude
I'm pretty close to you I'm I'm pretty
close to you you got me beat but not by
much
all right so get to the roof right now
yeah I've been checking the Outpost
let's see do I have any from Weasley
oh wait I got one from Lucan
wait what
I already read that but I didn't know
you
he doesn't he doesn't have a quest on my
oh wait who's this
are these old I'm so confused now
oh Natty I had two for Maddie
Sir Nicholas our house ghost is looking
for you can find him near the Great Hall
it's old though I feel like I've already
done that
yeah like I've already done that with
garlic when guardian Leviosa okay so
some of these are old now that one is
new how would you like to learn not back
jinx lapindo
can't find any good weight a part of it
I'm not sure what you mean Hermione
well baby I will all get together on a
live stream again oh I know dude I know
I like when I was playing it
last week all I wanted to do is I I got
I need to talk to somebody about this
but I could talk to I mean there are a
few people I could talk to but still
it's like everybody's playing the game
so yeah I can't wait to get together and
talk with a bunch of people
I know I need to learn flippindo they're
old if the photo shows yeah I thought
like if they were
if I hadn't read them they would be like
closed that's what I was thinking
like I should have a
yeah we've already done that somebody
asked the best way to get coins I mean
you could sell your gear because you
keep your
you keep the appearance even if you sell
the gear
so
and then also you can do
um those little uh what are they called
the disillusionment chest
they give you 500 every time you do one
of those
so that's pretty cool
all right okay I got I got thrown off
now I gotta get back to uh
going for the poppy Quest oh the yeah
the one we got to see
yeah last from water that's what I was
thinking yeah that was disillusionment
give you the 500. revelio
all right I don't even remember what the
last thing we did
we need to save you from these
barbarians
oh we got a break
okay
any letters or anything we can pick up
here
doesn't look like it
oh
that's on the other side though or no
maybe that's we got to get up to a
different level
oh the little puff skins
okay this is one thing I don't I don't
like that the bag is like a spell
I wish it was like an essential
all right we're gonna rescue don't worry
we're gonna rescue you
more in here
oh no but they're oh wait that is one oh
they're not even moving they're just so
scared
foreign
XP so
all of the Little Field Guide pages are
really good
and they're pretty uh they're they're
very plentiful you can find lots of them
in Hogwarts
and I mean really everywhere but there's
a lot of them concentrated of course in
Hogwarts
oh wow
it's like messages from the pope
poachers
oh goodness 2 30 for you wow
oh does your stream just end last
Marauder
oh man
thank you dude hey get some rest get
some rest hope you have a good uh
a nice lengthy sleep
Mr Moe what's up dude thank you for
stopping by
yeah I'm having a really good time with
it having a really good time
all right we gotta figure out how to get
out of here can I move
oh right there
wait really we're not supposed to go
through there
oh dude
that totally looks like a place
that you should be able to climb up to
right there
oh this was a shorter stream oh yeah I
was thinking I was like wasn't the 24
hour one
the other day
yeah good night dude good night
hey Shelby how's it going yeah so right
now we're just trying to
complete our next Quest here this is the
quest with Daddy
and high wing
oh there's stuff over there that we
haven't gotten either
can we accio these nope
all right so there's gotta be something
either in here
oh I guess we can just go around and go
up now we're gonna be where that blue
yeah where that thing is
get some coin wow the six coins
six coins
some side quests you can basically ask
for money oh and they won't give it to
you unless you ask that's funny
I have seen a couple quests like that
though where it gives you the option to
be like uh I demand or uh I would like
some payment
revelio
yeah Martin going with the Merlin robes
Astrid keep an eye on my stash a it's
yours if I mysteriously disappear that
liar cheated us out of what was ours so
I took what I could and hid it here
yeah okay
blue leather gloves oh that's an upgrade
though
let's go to our gear menu
right there
no wait where'd it go
where'd it go I just saw 191. oh it's
wait why is it locked
I don't think I've ever seen one locked
before I guess I have to go to the room
of requirement
how's it going Simeon it's going well
dude really enjoying the game I'm really
enjoying it
but everybody got too far ahead of me so
trying to I'm trying to knock out some
story stuff tonight
yeah I do already have the broom I do
have the broom
dead werewolf in the mountains oh my
gosh
oh is it a level lock let's see because
it was just it was just a green oh yeah
26 and I'm only at 25.
good call good call that one we still
have to go to the
whatever that little thing is called in
the room of requirement
yeah level locked
you enjoying it Jake yeah it's pretty
fun dude revelio it's pretty fun
all right so I guess we just go back
here now
because I don't think wait hold on
before I walk all the way back over
there
is there any other way
oh wait can we just hop up here
all right I don't think so I think we're
supposed to go back
I think we're supposed to go back
revelio
going up
oh there's there's a highway
it's all right
there we go
oh are we gonna get the fly Manny
fly her out of here
oh another one we gotta set both of them
free
there we go
come on Daddy get on get on
oh no
why is that one running flying away
have fun with us
there we go
I did go back dearly I did go back
[Music]
oh you got a while Jake you got a while
if you want to unlock all that stuff
just make sure you do like stick to
story quests really
let's go
oh this is awesome the highway
this is awesome
I can definitely tell oh look at the
train
there's the Hogwarts Express must be
returning from an unscheduled run
interesting why would it be doing an
unscheduled run
the music right here let's go
all right so like you press R2 and
that's what makes the wings
oh didn't mean to do that Highway sorry
nah I'm gonna choose not to learn AK on
this playthrough
what common room should you choose
I mean you could take the quiz take the
quiz on Wizarding World and see see
where you end up
I see I'm so tempted I wonder if you can
pop the balloons
man I saw something so awesome the other
day
I wasn't streaming and I don't I may
have been recording my gameplay though I
may have been recording there was a
hypocrite that just came out of nowhere
it flew down low to the water
and then grabbed a fish out of the water
it was so awesome
it's incredible just like totally it
wasn't part of a mission or anything
oh look at the sunrise
oh this is so good this is so good
[Music]
you didn't you got Gryffindor there you
go
there you go
[Music]
I'm enjoying it a lot Northwoods
enjoying it a lot
how to get to the train station you can
get to it by by just um I don't know the
exact Direction I passed over it there
that just happened in the mission I
wasn't sure we were going to make it out
alive
there was nothing
It's all under control were you able to
find the letter summoned it straight out
of Harlow's hands nice nice I will say I
did not expect to see him cast The
Killing cast at us he won't forget this
yeah I found the dark arts Christy it's
in the Forbidden Forest that rookwood's
looking for a phoenix
I'm not sure where he will find one whoa
I'm looking forward to Phoenix to
inspect that castle for the poachers
enough to connect Harlow to the crimes
I shall deliver the letter the letter to
officer singer she'll have to do
something when she sees it now tell me
where did you meet these hippogriffs
I've only met Highway before poppy
introduced us puppy Sweeting knows a
hippogriff
of course she does poppy will be
relieved to know that highway is safe
I came to the right person for help my
mother will be worried I must go seek me
out soon I shall have much to tell you
just got alohomora so easy on PC I mean
it feels a lot easier on Console now too
I don't know if it's just we're used to
it now
wait do I just get tall
new item unlocked oh these are our
pre-order things
what
so palkria and caligo and high Wing new
B slot inventory let's go dude when you
have a moment please stop
stop room of requirement okay hold on
Weasley hold on
okay oh my goodness they're all gonna
start talking aren't they
Wing I just wanna I just wanna share I
just want to have this moment with the
hippogriff first
okay so let me read this here take
flight is X R2 is hold Gallop or you can
use L3
and then Circle this mount
oh dude
High Wing go all right broom is cool
this might be cooler
wow man look at that
oh yeah some people are asking about we
could fly over to that cave if you want
oh I love how the camera kind of zooms
out like that
oh dude we need it we need a screenshot
of this right
here
I wish I would have turned off the other
part of the HUD but
oh and then you can get the Dive Right
There
that's so cool
the Beast animation is so lovely I know
but now it's like I unlock the thestral
too
all right so if we start sewing down
can you go in the water
High wing
I don't think you can go in the water
can you
yeah she's kind of just like hovering
right there
all right so let's see can we land here
nope I don't think we can land here
either
all right let's just get over here on a
nice flat area
foreign
oh you have to
oh you have to you oh that's okay so
it's different from the broom you have
to use the right stick to descend all
the way down oh what
what
thank you
is that is that like a scripted thing
does everybody see that
is that
does that always happen right after you
get the hippogriff
oh
my goodness
oh it's just gone it is gone
now
I was just too I was frozen I couldn't
move
I cannot believe that just happened
has any has anyone seen that happen
Mr screenshot well hey the good thing is
this is all live and being recorded as
we speak
oh my goodness oh you know what and the
PS5 also has a great feature where I can
save recent gameplay
I'm gonna say last let's say last 15
minutes just to be sure
you've seen the dragon flying around
it is scripted okay so is it like
guaranteed I guess it's guaranteed to
happen after you get the hippogriff at
some point maybe
oh my goodness Chase it down oh it's
long gone now I've just been like Frozen
in place here not able to move
foreign
so how do I
okay Highway can be mounted again
through the tool Wheel by holding L1 oh
this is so cool
this is so cool so how do I change it
out though
the animations
no Diego I hadn't done that yet
I had not done that yet
all right hold on we gotta we gotta
figure this out how to uh switch oh it's
not what I meant to do
all right so
I don't see anywhere to switch it here
so maybe it's somewhere in our
in our menu here
all right maybe under gear oh there we
go
Okay so we've got Calico
so this was the Onyx hippogriff that we
unlocked as a pre-order
and then we have sepulchria a tame and
gentle female thestral that will allow
you to soar through the clouds on her
back
can you actually oh dude the thestrals
are so much
so much thinner
oh dude I think I think I'm gonna go
with with caligo but I want to try out
I want to try out the thestral too
all right so to do this we hold L1 and
then triangle
oh my gosh the animation sightseeing are
just so ridiculously good see if it's
the same controls yeah it is so you can
just like hold R2 you just kind of do
this this little Gallop here on the
ground
then we're gonna go here away
away
looks a little uncomfortable
indeed
I don't know if you can crash or not
though that's a good question dude now I
just want to just
keep flying around and it that dragon
scene I cannot believe that
can we get a giant squid sighting too
that'd be awesome wouldn't it
be awesome if we could get it let's see
how low you can get to the water
oh you oh
they even let you
no way
they thought of everything
you guys see that
oh my gosh dude
that is so cool
right Micah I just continue to see
things that
okay I don't think you can crash because
if you could I feel like I would have
totally crashed right there right I
wanna I need to slow down we slow down
for just a little bit there we go
and then there's one more up here
yeah that industrial spine
a little bit more uncomfortable than the
hippogriff probably
you saw the squid today randomly when
you're flying over I saw the squid once
but I think that one was definitely
scripted because it happened when
somebody said something about
a squid
and that's when it happened
I just I am just still like trying to
process that moment that was so epic
try Landing without stopping all right
let's see what happens if we just go
straight down right here
just immediately lands
so it is quite different from the uh
when you can collect while you're still
riding that's nice that's a nice touch
go
all right and I need to race down my
friend L1
oh no you push wait
oh you just Dismount with circle okay
that's
that's weird because that's different
from the broom
all right now let's try out the other
one the Onyx
the Onyx hippogriff
all right back to gear
oh and we have one more slot
all right so we've got the Onyx
hippogriff now
can you cast spells while riding the
only one is revelio
oh wait you can walk through the water
see what happens
no way they can swim too
oh it's still pretty shallow right here
so we're just walking through
does it not get deep here
I want to see what happens when it gets
deeper
yeah so if you try to cast normal spells
nothing happens but revelio gets still
cast
for some reason it's not letting me jump
though like I can't
I can't take flight from here
whereas the broom you can like with the
broom you can just jump right out from
the water
foreign
because you got to get a little bit of a
maybe you have to get that running start
seeing the spots where you can dive
I'm not sure what you mean Johnny I
don't think so
I'm not sure when you get the hogsmeade
shop I haven't done that I have not done
that yet
it's hard to get out of the water with
wings yeah yeah exactly
dude this is so cool
it's just so cool
and I feel like it's differentiated
enough from the broom
it feels really different really
different
all right so then
oh yeah just I keep forgetting how you
dismount
yeah the boat house over there
revelio
[Music]
you go check it out let's see if there's
any students over there
when we had the little preview event
and I flew over here some students just
randomly appeared right when I landed
let's see if that's still
uh none over here but there is student
right here I Think Like a Stone
Narita Roberts
you can go in The Boathouse too
come on let me drive the boat
incending
yes let's go
I wish I could find that Dragon oh
man I I just froze like I didn't know
what
I wish we would have followed it too
that would have been so I would love to
just see where it goes you know
yeah I love Deke
is fun
revelio
oh oh oh hold on I heard it
there it is
[Music]
Black Lake the Black Lake or Great Lake
the sitting Headmaster vainly prefers
the prior it's an expanse of freshwater
south of the castle the Lakes murky
depths are home to mer people credilos
and other magical aquatic beasts and
beings including the giant squid a
surprisingly friendly cephalopod with a
fondness for toast
that is so funny
goodness no though I'm beginning to
think I really should learn how to swim
can't very well be liaison to the mer
people if I don't know how to swim
liaison
what technically no at least not yet
the position doesn't actually exist at
the moment but I have a plan to change
that
I'm narrator by the way nerds Roberts we
didn't officially narrator okay
yes of course good to see you again and
you you seem quite interested in my
people
and tours have liaison officers at the
ministry then the mer people should have
one too
uh
I think what you're doing is admirable
I'm impressed I think reaching out to
the ma people is a grand idea you do oh
I'm sure Shelby yeah
exactly
I guarantee
give go and then
in one of their caves
reciprocity and an offer to visit I
tried telling them I couldn't swim but
I'm afraid that Bitcoin this is tricky
murmish really is tricky
oh let's see
what would a liaison can you imagine a
liaison to them are people would do oh
so many things I want to know everything
I can about them
after I've mastered swimming I perfect
my mermish of course and I'd share with
them anything they wanted to know about
wizard kind my hope is that by
understanding each other better both of
our societies could grow
maybe that's what what's the current
relationship with short and it's
treatment of ma people well we've
consistently dained my people as being
beneath us despite the many similarities
between our cultures one can hardly
blame them for declining being satisfied
yeah that is cool who are we to classify
those as such beauty and intelligence
and I don't even know what's so
interesting I know what's interesting oh
I can swim and could help you if you'd
like you'd really
thank you the last thing I want is for
them to think I'd shunned their gift
diplomacy is a day have fun Christy have
fun now if I'm not mistaken I think you
can dive down to their cave water
I can't wait I care about what you find
I can go one day soon I'll see for my
itself
are you serious right now
look at this place
oh my goodness really leave Noida an
artifact oh man I was hoping I was
thinking the whole thing was going to be
underwater
ing crazy Luke now then I'll need you to
come with me
I'll need you okay we got two other ones
here so three total
there we go for the rest of you
make sure there's nothing else here that
I want to collect
lumos
you just did this this one Alex nice
yeah this was just a random one that I
stumbled upon I didn't even like
incendio pull it up in my menu or
anything I just ended up close by lumos
said let's do this one oh look at look
at the pictures right there
oh you can see the mermaid and then the
grindelos around
all right
let us proceed further
Naruto will be happy about this
a murmish artifact
all right no okay that was just too easy
I expected to be attacked by something
Rebellion
I was definitely expected to get
attacked is that it
no attack all right let's go back
yeah technically you can dive in some
specific situations
okay
whoops didn't mean to hop off that early
your gift from the ma people was exactly
where they said it would be
[Music]
so worried
let's seen it as a slight our
relationship with them is already so
tenuous hey no problem Randall thanks
for stopping by
and um ninja dogs so make sure that you
you have to link you have to um claim it
on both twitch and the Hogwarts Legacy
drop site
you have to claim it in both places
so go to hogwartslexi.com click on
Twitch Drops make sure you have
everything linked there
um and then there like once you've got
it unlocked on Twitch then there will be
a button there that you have to click to
unlock
then reboot your game and they should
pop they should come through then
gift oh my gosh
I can't wait for my evil playthrough
I'm glad we helped to Foster some
healthy diplomatic relations we're good
we're good display through guys
I'm going to show it to everyone
including the ministry
should I hand deliver or send by Owl
thank you again so much you may have
just nice relationship I hope we helped
that much for decades to come
I don't know if it helped that much but
maybe you never know right
I think the content is dropping slowly
so the um
the Merlin one straight up wasn't
working for a lot of people like I know
Elwyn was trying to get it and wasn't
able to get it
but the ones that you get by watching
twitch streamers those all seem to be
working fine
and progressing as they should
all right let's go ahead and open up our
Quest log again
and let's see what we've got next on the
story how do you link your wand
um if you go to
if you just Google search Wizarding
World
Hogwarts Legacy account link or
something like that it should pop up you
basically have to link your WB and your
Wizarding World accounts
and then you have to make sure that your
WB account is linked to whatever
platform you're playing on and then once
once everything's linked up I mean it
works perfectly you just like I had all
mine set up before the game came out
and as soon as I fired it up everything
Pops in immediately
all right let's do astronomy class next
and let's go into the map
yeah Ninja Dog there there's like that
one little extra step that is
not very clear unless you go to the if
you read like that full FAQ but it's
it's a lot it's a lot to read we just
read it on stream the other day so
that's
that's the only reason I know
all right so that is up there oh my
goodness we got so many quests
for students and stuff
all right we'll go to the charms
classroom
there you go thank you Elwyn nice
dude I've got to figure out what is
going on with this monitor man
why does it keep
it just keeps losing its connection hold
on give me one second guys I'm gonna see
if I can't
if there's not a setting here
let's see that I have just like enabled
by accident Maybe
overdrive I wonder if I turn overdrive
off
all right we're gonna try that no
overdrive
it was on picture quality
test that for a little bit see if that
works
yeah they do have a divination class
they do have a divination
I think I've had one so far
foreign nope that didn't work
I just did the flicker on me again there
goes peeves
whoa
yeah no problem fishy no problem
and whenever you link that like oh room
a requirement I didn't realize we were
gonna pass so close to it
hello there
astronomy Tower flu Flames let's go
revelio
oh oh I heard it hold on
might be one down here that I missed
now it sounded like it was above
okay definitely was above
he's jump scare I know what like what
the heck
what is that oh wait maybe it's in here
no
in here
what
revelio
oh another letter
oh my goodness I don't know if I'm gonna
read the whole thing
oh let's see
oh it's a letter to her sister
well we'll read it there might be
something here my dear satyavati
you'll be pleased to hear that I
received word from my contacts at
Cambridge who conceded that they had in
fact been incorrect in their
understanding of meteor showers it seems
that an Irish astronomer and a British
astronomer both built upon the work done
by an Italian astronomer all Muggles
mind you as far as I know to propose a
calculating the position of the Dust at
Earth's orbit as means of connecting
meteors to comets brilliant really one
can only imagine what they might do with
an enchanted telescope frustratingly in
my correspondence I did feel that I had
to continue using the pseudonym for my
days as a gentleman scholar whilst I
still find it rather exciting to have a
secret identity the reason irks me I'm
so looking forward to our trip later
this year to Jantar mantar what an
adventure we shall have miss you dear
sister and do hope you are well
they were yeah they were very right
about getting lost
and it does look good fishy what's crazy
is like I'm on performance mode too it
looks even better in Fidelity but I just
I just prefer the higher frame rates
let's do this
okay see you right there I just
immediately went up down left right and
if I go left
it automatically is gonna start working
okay so I was trying the same thing with
the red to no luck so I'm gonna have to
turn that one a little bit
oh it was in this area there we go
athletic house robe
I probably should have stopped by the
rumor requirement as well
dude where was that field guide page
I don't hear it anymore now
interesting
and yes dearly I get lost all I mean
just and you don't mind getting lost
like that's the thing you just want to
keep exploring
okay what was like there was something I
was oh yeah gear gear gear
okay oh another level lock I need to get
to 26. I also need to identify that
and okay that one I can put on and that
one I can put on but this one is better
right here
foreign
and I need to go sell soon I'm only at
I'm at 27.
all right let's put Merlin back on
maybe the sound was because the letter
oh maybe maybe
put Merlin's cloak back on
yeah maybe it was just something
discoverable I always thought it was
like a field guide page but you could be
right maybe it's just like telling you
something revelio
mind
all right you know what I'm not going to
activate that just yet let's just run
back down we were so close to the rumor
requirement
let's just go ahead and
go in here
I wish there was some place you could
sell at Hogwarts I wonder if there's
anywhere you can I don't think there is
like cell gear inside of Hogwarts
all right the Mandrake is ready
good I needed one of those
and we'll go ahead and grow another one
oh yeah Deke wants to talk to us about
something too
all right so then this right here
identification station
I'm at 25 and I need to get to 20 or 26.
all right so let's see if we can equip
any of those or if they're also level
locked
all right nothing higher there
oh that's higher
oh my gosh asylum mask
no thank you
we'll keep it on because of the uh
the Boost to the stats but
increased venomous tentacular damage on
this the traits
yeah thanks Elwyn yeah I'm on PC
yeah Panda exactly I put up a short
about that today
it's on the channel here if you if you
look through my shorts yeah it's it's
basically how their transmog system
works it's really nice so you can equip
any piece of gear and then just make it
look like whatever you want and you can
also sell so like let's say
like this these gray Quidditch
gloves right there like let's just say I
love the look of those I can still sell
the gear piece
but the appearance of those gloves
I can still have
that's what I had on right there
and because you change the appearance
you just hit Square so see how when I
hover there right there at the bottom it
says change appearance
yeah it's a really nice feature
really nice feature
oh for the lock pick spell I'm on uh I
just have the first level one yeah is
all I have right now
okay let's
let's think we could upgrade anything
else
but yeah now we need to we need to sell
some stuff
foreign
let's go ahead and do that mission for
oh no let's talk to Deke let's see what
he wants
where is he hilarious
I hope it doesn't start a mission though
oh I think it does
that's fine
Professor Weasley said you wanted to
tell me more about the loom ah hello uh
yes about that oh that would be nice
David yeah hey
Craig that's a good idea
foreign
setting back on the monitor since it
didn't help any
all right hold on one second guys I'm
gonna see if this will work it seems the
room thinks you need more space for your
beasts as Deke was saying he's had a
thought now DEET knows how you can test
the item of clothing that you enhanced
in the Enchanted Loom and perhaps help
an old friend in the process what do you
mean a house self named tobs works for
his master retrieving leech juice in a
cave near Hogwarts Tubb's Master doesn't
let him leave the cave and he knows the
cave is infested with spiders that
sounds awful it is Deke hasn't heard
from his friend for a while now
as the item you wove in the loom has an
enchantment that might be useful Deek
thought you could test it whilst
checking on tobs
all right I think I might have fixed it
guys I think I might have fixed it there
was a setting in my monitor that was
like
notify you when there's a resolution
change or something and that's what kept
popping up
uh if it helps me oh my gosh no I'll
find it leave it to me dick I'll find
tops for you oh thank you how could you
use that
dude's old friend
Hogwarts like as he keeps crashing in
Steam oh I do not ruinic
I know that uh Elwyn is on PC I know
Nico they're two moderators here they're
both on PC
I do not know I do know that WB support
has been really active on Twitter so you
might want to hit them up see if they
might be able to help
yeah I'm I'm playing on PS5
all right so before we do are we already
in the middle of that mission though now
did we like just get that mission
started with Deke I hope not
but I think we may have
I think we may have
foreign
like story stuff as well yeah
basically like not I'm just kind of
going through the game at this point
okay so we could do that but we don't
have to do that
I think I'm gonna go to this one let go
because we were so close
lucky thanks for all the hard work you
did up to the game release got you so
hyped oh nice glad to hear it lucky
thank you for being here and and
supporting the channel we got a lot more
in store let me tell you a lot more I'm
hoping to have a video actually after we
wrap up with the stream tonight I've got
a
record and edit and hopefully have it
ready by tomorrow
a video
but then we're also going to be
streaming tomorrow as well
I know Mrs raconteur Deke so you better
not die like like another of our
favorite house elves
35 gotta catch up what's up Cloud Roth
think you just go to the cave okay good
Diego yeah that's
it looked like it let me switch
just finish your first trial nice
oh we're waiting on your physical copy
nice
well it will be worth the wait worth the
wait why is it showing me the
oh it was literally just the exclamation
point to say hey
you've oh
okay that must be what happened earlier
too because I clicked on it was like I
don't have anything to upgrade here
what's going on
foreign
let's check our inventory oh we got all
our little creatures
little puff schemes
or something else that wants me to look
at an inventory
oh yeah the Rune diagram that we picked
up
oh wait does it want me to actually view
each of these
that's showing the exclamation point
foreign
oh yeah that was that was a really
I don't know if you guys found this
letter right here
there's a guy that you can find out in
the world who has been attacked
and he is no longer living
and by him you find this letter from
Olive Ander
very sad
your game got canceled
what Alexander what do you mean how did
it get canceled can you just like order
a digital copy or were you wanting
physical
yeah runics that is shown the answer to
that is shown
I don't know if you want it spoiled or
not but it happens it happens pretty
early in the game
plot twist Deke is done he's great great
I mean it's possible Right
it's possible
all right I still I'm gonna hold off on
the one Talent
and hold off on that
actually have I been in here long enough
to get another Mandrake
yeah thank you Alexander appreciate you
stopping by
yeah I hate to hear that you're uh
something happened with your order
though that's unfortunate
all right so we're back out now
and I think it was this way
and I would be wrong
they're just one a ghost
I heard it again I heard it there is
another one close by somewhere
yeah yeah they do show it yep
you got canceled on February 6th oh
yeah that's weird that they would cancel
that late in the game
and your reading is the Dragon
that's exciting I suppose
oh what does that mean for an adventure
Professor Shaw
astronomy is not divination
you won't find the mysteries of the
cosmos charted out on your bombs or at
the bottom of your oh what's up
Professor Baxter alas the heavens remain
hazy thank you for stopping by I get it
I get it if you want to divorce
yeah and we are we are doing story stuff
tonight so
with that in mind please take your
telescopes tonight we will be on the
observation deck
on the observation deck okay
okay still don't have your own you can't
be the new student forever you know you
can share with Mr takar
Mr takar
here I can adjust that foreign
she's like no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
whoa
I can't believe they put astronomy in
the game expect all of you that is
awesome
Mia Cole didn't stop the great
stargazers of the past look only to the
astronomy tables oh you're fine you're
fine from which they gave is Millennia
ago on the very self-same stars above us
is that clear
oh what's his name I keep forgetting
that guy's name
something with an L Leon or uh
oh hello I'm Amit we met in potions
class
I'm happy to report that we've yet to
have any experience Meander that's it
thank you hello mate
see you again did I hear Professor Shaw
say that you don't have your own
telescope
I have a spare one you could borrow for
the rest of term
oh that's right he loves uh he loves
telescopes that's very kind of you I
mean studying astronomy are you sure you
won't need it I'm certain it's good
fishy it's good I finally what's up Ryan
from the new Celestia contemplore you've
heard of it I assume I mean of course
you have no it's only the Pinnacle of
all personal star gazing implements but
my old model's not too shabby either
Goblin cut glass First Rate Optical
enchantments hate to think such a fine
instrument is just I will take it off
your hands thank you Amit think nothing
of it anyway the telescopes in the
storage room why does our character keep
saying Ami I have some uh I said a meat
breeding to finish on the lower deck
come find me there afterwards and bring
the telescope
there's something I want to talk to you
about oh something he wants to talk to
us about okay okay okay
revelio
oh that one's definitely close by
how am I supposed there
I'm Gryffindor fishy
this telescope is the finest stargazing
instrument of its kind perfect for
viewing the moon and the stars and
anything else one might find in the
night sky
oh I remember this guy oh me thinks he
heard
sounded like gibberish to me
I had heard about these Odd Stone tables
out in the island
okay that was weird Tasha was talking
just happened with the
weather right there I do love
how after the classes you have like
these little interactive moments with
the students if you if you choose most
all of them
okay looks like you can't interact with
him this time oh he did look up at us
constellations of
not sure they're worth dying of a cold
for me oh beautiful
and then our buddy uh Professor Shaw is
just about holding distance as the
bloody Stars she wants us to chart not
how I wanted to spend my evening
all right am I supposed to do anything
else I don't think so
we can talk to one more person try to
put off my stargazing as long as I could
hey Leander I wasn't talking to you how
am I supposed to find Syria so my hands
are too cold serious
oh oh wait different series different
series
what a nice reference though right you
know why they put that in there
you know exactly why they put that in
there and then even had the comment
about the dog
which of course you know the
constellation probably why he was named
series to begin with anyway
all right and we've got oh there's the
telescope telescope
let's pray he did his waiting
how do we not just light everything in
there on fire
it's all good it's all good
all right is there anything
now we just go back up
oh we can talk to you too stargazing
Professor Shaw
I'm interested in learning more about
astronomy oh suck up
rare to find a student who seeks after
things Celestial dude look at her
character model
oh my God the causes of the cosmos you
must read your mind of the terrestrial
bubble of others we ourselves are not
unlike blank starches that is such a
great empty characters is waiting to be
inscribed with all that the universe to
offer
offer do you understand
uh I notice you dismissed divination am
I right in thinking you are unimpressed
by divination of the many other
so-called disciplines taught here
divination is perhaps the most feeble
especially in its nonsensical practice
of astrology do not confuse astronomy
and astrology one is concerned with
Mysteries Stella and Luna the other is
mere lunacy
um okay
you mentioned astronomy tables earlier
in class
what were you talking about long ago
devotees of the astral Arts secretary
stone slabs across the countryside they
are ideal for studies yes we need to
find these for centuries Wizards made
use of these astronomy tables for
stargazing sadly they have since become
mere monuments to the Intrepid
intellectual Pursuits of a bygone epoch
a bygone epoch thank you all right I
look forward to stargazing I am glad to
hear it should be a stellar night for it
okay so now we actually have to go over
and killing you oh no peas is still
lurking about oh wait how do we use it
can we not use it up here
all right I guess we have to go
yeah that's what I was thinking
yeah Diego it's so cool like talking for
that extra conversation
I have the telescope it's nicer than I'd
expected I would not offer a prospective
Stargazer a third-rate Luna scope
but there is
um something else yes what is it you
remember those astronomy table saw was
going on about it just so happened I've
been reading up on them a little myself
yeah I agree amazing figs model looks so
good if we could use it to find hidden
constellations
oh
are you in no return the gobstones club
will go with me said they'd rather get
spit at by a stone then
well they are cowards let us get moving
while the stars are still out I'll show
you how to use that telescope once we
get there I promise
uh
sounds exciting no need to convince me
let's get going brilliant you won't
regret it shall we yeah crucio already
a secret entrance to hogsmead
Maybe
the table is on a castle wall ahead look
for a stone platform something that
doesn't quite belong oh wait okay he's
accompanying us
ravenclaws
there you go marked by centaurs for
rituals I think this qualifies as a
companion dude
I think it qualifies
it is nice having a fellow Stargazer to
explore with
happy to be here it is good to leave the
classroom now and then
oh my goodness the flickering on my
monitor is getting worse guys I don't
know why it's doing this
it's not here it's totally dark right
now I'm having a watch from the uh oh
why don't
My Stream is usual
you want me to lead the way okay fine
hmm rebellious
oh a few cobwebs and some dust nothing
to be concerned about now it's back oh
of course it's just not as tidy as I
expected
so there are companions but they're
Mission exclusive
oh you like yeah it doesn't seem like at
least I haven't gotten to a point yet it
doesn't seem like that they're you're
gonna hit a point where you can just
invite whatever companion you want now
there is kind of that in the crossed
wands maybe that happens later actually
I take that back there was a mission
early on where Weasley asked me who I
wanted to take
and it was natsight or Sebastian
but here lately I haven't I haven't seen
seen that kind of option caged bathtub
what in the world
this bathtub has been kept behind lock
and key for as long as anyone can Berra
rumor has it that the tub was enchanted
to chase after students decades ago who
were too obsessed with their studies to
care for much personal hygiene
wow
revelio
all right what else it means what else
could I ask you something oh
um certainly
that was I knew I had heard that
dialogue before
you hate opening the chest with the eye
opening on the back
uh
why the Fascinations are so fascinated
with stars I suppose because there is so
much to learn about them that's not a
bad idea
after stream tonight yeah Limitless
always something new being discovered
they are forever discovering new Moons
and stars in fact they discovered a new
planet just 50 years ago
okay sorry I get it
where precisely is the table we're
looking for according to an old
astronomical Chronicle I found in the
library it may be somewhere along the
castle wall
okay actually it's all actually that's
all I wanted to know very well then
favorite spell oh that's tough
um
I mean like these four have kind of been
my go-to they're also four that you
unlock
pretty early we got the pulso accio
levioso and then incendio
we're thinking fringo's really good
Expelliarmus is really good glacias I
need to I need to use more often
accio is just great because it's so just
useful for so many things apparently you
can destroy these right here too
all right let's see anything else we
need to do in here we can talk to you
again I'll meet could I ask you
something oh oh um certainly
oh we already asked this
where precisely is the table we already
asked
actually that's all I wanted to know oh
very well then
stupefy oh that's a good like protego
that's a really good one because
vertigo is ridiculously powerful
it's kind of like your bread and butter
when you're fighting I mean
you just really need to get the timing
down
you get the perfect parry and you hold
down for stupid pie yeah it's really
nice you don't think any spiders might
be lurking about oh I do I'm not this
close to school I mean
I think you should do that I don't know
try it out
oh this is it revelio
okay what am I supposed to do
oh right there we can put the telescope
on it the constellation should appear I
am seriously blown away that they put
astronomy in this game
that is actually so cool
oh wait can we I was gonna say can we
lined up the telescope we will be able
to dude this is great
this is so good I was right about the
tables they really are gateways to the
far Stars just as the book said
and your contribution was invaluable
rest assured you shall be credited in my
Memoirs one day let's go
look forward to that thank you Amit I
look forward to reading hey have a good
one Rooney have a good one thank you for
stopping by
it's like this one throughout the
grounds and four
ever seen one it's you oh and about my
old telescope don't bother returning it
you should I thought that's what you
said to begin with generous thank you
you're welcome a romantic night was
right stargazing with a meat I'm
practically fluent in gobbledygook you
know it's all in the throat really
gobbledygook you know and and how you
pronounce your r's
um anyway so I mean I don't know about
you guys I feel like that qualifies as
companion
he accompanied you on a mission now will
it last though right like will it will
there be any more I mean he's got a
whole challenge that you unlock with him
ah never do get tired and it's
considered a main quest
what a view
oh my goodness we have gotten a lot more
from Nat's eye and natsai and Sebastian
we're gonna go confront him regarding
the goblin you mentioned
I'm ready for the next map
s who else who else is trying to reach
me anybody else
oh my goodness Ryan it's 3 42 for you do
you normally stay up that I don't you
could be waking up
or you could be staying up I don't know
which one
Jake how do you get the yellow line and
remove the map
oh so yeah you go into it's the very
last like option over here
if you go into your settings
this one all the way down
and then show minimap you can turn it
off
and then whenever you have one of your
quests marked I think it's I need to
test this out more I think it's only
like your main quests but like if I mark
this one right here go to the map
chamber with fig
and then I'm going to hit up on the
d-pad
and that will like show me a trail of
which way I need to go
it's pretty handy
it's pretty handy indeed wait so I guess
are we done I guess we're done with the
astronomy class
hold on I kind of want to see if she had
any more dialogue though Professor Shaw
like after we completed that section
revelio
but I guess technically once we left and
came down here that was
can I use this anytime he's like they
studied
oh no I guess you can only use them for
one time
wait is this where we no that's the
allery right there
toothache kept you awake oh that's
unfortunate
cat Dad how's it going dude what is up
I actually went to the dentist today as
well but thankfully no cavities
thankfully no cavities is this
underground where in the world
if they added getting in trouble for
being out during night time that isn't
part of a quest yeah somebody asked me
that question on uh
on a video they said can you get in
trouble for sneaking out and I was like
sort of
oh it is underground
see
let's go we'll go to this flu Flame
oh yeah because it's that map chamber
actually I just realized that there's a
faster way to get to it
it's if you go here and then you go over
to it's called like um
so you go into the Hogwarts map
it's like special secret rooms secret
rooms
the map chamber
all right you know what it's still doing
this flickering I'm gonna try to just
unplug my HDMI
and plug it back in
hopefully it doesn't kill the whole
stream
foreign
all HDMI cables
[Music]
have been securely
connected
rip right yeah I knew it would cut out
for a second but hopefully we're still
good
now I just have to
go back to my input
oh my favorite character
hmm
so far
I thought I didn't have sound I thought
it had lost sound
oh I mean I really love Deke I always
love the house elves like Dobby was one
of my favorites
mcgonagall's pretty McGonagall Weasley's
pretty cool I mean she seems like she
really has it together since black
doesn't do anything
all right so now we're ready to go right
into the map chamber these are my
favorite missions so far like when
you're with fig and you're learning
about the ancient magic stuff
something big always happens on these
you would be wise not to underestimate
this yeah that's right the aptitude for
magic is beyond anything I've ever seen
I'm right here I've been teaching a long
time appreciate it dude it is a joy to
have such a student yeah that's me can
we that's me
there you are
I'm here fig
I've received your owl I was able to
speak with lodgok the goblin I mentioned
before Lord what did you learn he and
ran Rock were close once but they had a
falling out you believe he can be
trusted
hey Johnny have a good one thank you for
stopping by oh you believe he can be
trusted I honestly don't like he said
something at the end of that mission
that made me a little bit suspicious
but I feel like they wanted it to be
like that because they want you to be
thinking of like grip Hook from the
books which we know grip hook it's like
Harry they never really trusted him I'm
gonna say difficulties trustworthy
difficult to know really but surrender
Ryan trusts him well that's something I
suppose
supposing he can be trusted will he help
us get to ran Rock I retrieved a stolen
Helm he hopes to return to ranrock in
order to regain his life right right
let's hope your efforts result in our
learning something about ramrock's plan
he mentioned that van rock is searching
for something but he couldn't say what
perhaps that Helm will yield some
answers
so you kind of can't sleep he's
searching for something if you go into
your uh map and you wait an unusual
amount of activity goblins and wizards
and you're just like lay down wherever
you're at or sit down
Rockwood Castle
my former residence yes that castle is
also the location of your next trial
that was your Castle okay
you didn't see anything
speak with anyone I did not in fact I
did not make myself known I only
recently returned there and did not
recognize
I stayed out of sight so as not to tempt
my portraits destruction
well the HDMI didn't work it's still
flickering over here
I have some bad news buddy tell you that
Victor Rook would evidently your
descendant is a dark wizard in League
with Round Rock my descendant a dark
wizard oh he's so I'm afraid we've no
time to waste despite the obstacles that
clearly await you you must get to
Rookwood Castle immediately not only is
it the living happy trial it is home to
a source of power that would be
devastating in the wrong hands I do wish
we had the luxury of time however I do
not doubt your abilities find my
portrait there as soon as you can very
well sorry buddy we're on it best of
luck
no time to waste hey Ryan you're
supporting just by being here dude and I
always see you on the videos I always
see you commenting and
reacting on Twitter that's that is a
huge help
don't don't feel bad
morning routine DLC
all right where are we going hey where
are we going
all right let's speed up it come on
big let's go
fig oh
wait I probably just have to go to the
next step in the mission don't I
uh into our quests oh yeah we do Charles
rookwood's trial
first of all recommend Charles Rook
would want me to complete Charles's
trial as soon as possible I need to meet
Professor fig at Rookwood Castle all
right let's do some fast travel
a live stream chat once you get to play
the game over yeah I mean we're doing a
lot of streams we're gonna be doing a
lot of streams
all right so we can fast travel pretty
close to this
right here
sleeping DLC greater than quidditch DLC
I don't show how I'd far enough a place
like this
all right
whoa
huh
enjoy suffering do ya
excuse me
revelio
oh no sir
wait are they
foreign
a sitting DLC I have seen people who
really want sitting Smalls
you really want sitting oh no gear slots
are full oh that's right I said I needed
to go sell I should do that before I
even start this Quest
I really should
which I wonder if I do that can I come
back and
can I come back and still get this stuff
hey that one was worth grabbing though
ooh Goblin loyalist correspondence
man Rock suspects there's more of it and
feldcroft did not return until you found
it
found what
oh yeah I feel for sure that I'll be on
PC
ranrock demands an update have you found
it
maybe they're trying to find that Helm
that that we actually found
all right before we do this let's travel
to hogsmead
and we need to sell
foreign
which any shop doesn't really matter
always just do Pippins because it's
very close to this Flame
doesn't get any more cozy than Hulk's
meat any more cozy than Hulk's Mead
oh wait no don't need to go that far
because it's right here
hello Perry any assistance at all
oh yeah you can be of assistance because
we have so many things to sell here
all right no traits so I'm selling that
anything that's 26 though I don't want
to sell it
because I haven't even gotten to see if
I can use it yet
that one's 25.
see I still don't know if I'm
if I should be saving legendary gear or
not
like are these trait it really comes
down to if the trait level
if the trait slot level threes are
really worth it and also how far you can
upgrade it because you can only upgrade
it three times it says
[Music]
so I just want to make sure
as I I already sold a couple of the
legendary ones but
I think I might keep them just to be
sure again
save me a lot of time and trouble
all right 22. okay that's a 26. and
that's 26. even though it's a green
and then now it's 26 but it would
actually be worse on the offensive side
it is so strange I'm still I'm still
learning about how all that works
all right well the good news is now we
freed up some slots
oh yeah the portraits that play the
music yeah
oh wait we can't fly in Hogs me darn it
I was just gonna fly over back over
there but
since we can't we shall
fast travel back to right here
I wonder who lives here
yeah usually when you collect a set like
if yeah if you had the whole set
equipped
I just I need to experiment with how
much you can upgrade
each piece of gear because it looks like
you can only do it three times
oh can I get in here I think this is a
level two oh it's not
let's go oh okay lucky first get
wow
I thought I got them both first try
wouldn't get rid of trade items keep all
of the ones which don't have any you can
re-buy
yes yeah I'm a little bit hesitant on
the traits and on anything legendary to
be honest
dude what is this place
has a massive
a massive trunk right here with a
tattersall vest school uniform inside
foreign
so it seems like the loot is a smart
loot system I don't know if you can get
duplicates at all
surely you can right
I just don't think I've seen it oh and
of course there was a shop right here
where I could have sold
Bernard
Hello nice to meet you welcome I'm
Bernard India
sorry is there anything I can help you
never heard that pronounced Bernard but
okay
uh what can you tell me about this yeah
what sort of surviving what do you sell
here glad you asked I saw the finest
array of beasts hey there
side if you don't believe me feel free
to look about eventually you'll return
they always do
might you have any insight an incredibly
unpleasant Goblin called belgruff the
bludgeoner has been tormenting everyone
he encounters felcroft borders Goblin
country but we've always lived in peace
with their kind
until recently that is
some claim that belgruff and his
associates are in League with rather oh
interesting to it yeah whatever the case
Bernard meddling is devastating so I
said it everyone feels unsafe
it's quite serious
oh may I see your wares what do you have
for sale
today
Moon Cafe niffler fur
oh these can be
okay we already have
we have Java rolls we have Moon calves
we do not have nifflers yet we do have
puff skin so yeah we have no we don't
really need to go for any of these
except maybe that one
but money is kind of hard to come by
actually in this game so I'm I'm not
gonna buy anything I mentioned you're
welcome to stop by anytime
oh dude I forgot that I took my hood off
I need to put it back on
if had duplicates happened found them
extremely rare interesting
yeah I agree Baxter like the the voice
acting itself is actually really good
really good
I think they did a great job with the
actors and actresses
but yeah there was just something about
some of the mocap
for the facial animations still just
looks a little bit off
who is that talking like they're not
they're not showing up
oh there they are
wait is that the same goblins we just
took out
different ones
I've never seen a sword like it
oh you found a sword
Revenue too late for you to learn the
error
[Music]
which room is it
good question
um
it is cold
night dancer broom
a Nimble broom with an impressive Style
so I won't I have four total wildfire
and then Lickety Swift
and this is the one I started with
that's the one I picked first just the
Hogwarts house broom
but I quite like this night dancer one
um
nothing there okay
you join Hogwarts Legacy as a game
tester
no way you had to that is insane
he had to go by the controller vibration
alone
wow
all right I don't like that it pops up
that you have something there
when it's literally just the start of a
new one I wish it would only show up if
you have one that you need to unlock
ah
all right let's see
over here all right fig let's do this I
love these missions man always something
cool happens like story wise on these
what's going on here Professor Rookwood
was right the place is crawling with
Victor rookwood's lot and Ryan Rock's
loyalists
working together all right but it is not
a friendly Alliance I'm sure you'll
agree that we need to find a way in
other than the front gate do we go
oh man excuse me
okay let's I want to put up I forgot we
took our hood off let's put the hood
back on
there we go
and let's do
all right he said away in other than the
front gate
so you don't
I I haven't seen anything that lets you
pick the owl
all the all the beasts that you get in
the
room of requirement though like those
you you go out and you rescue them yeah
okay just want to make sure we got that
yeah this is like one of the main story
missions here what no no no no no no
all right he said just don't go in
through the main gate
so can we sneak up on this guy and then
do
a video
no you do not see me
all right
keep going this way
it is 11 p.m for me 11 P.M
over leveled if I just unlock the room
requirement to know their story pass on
level 24. uh yeah yeah you definitely
are
have you just unlocked the requirement
in your level 24 yeah you're you're
pretty over leveled
Revenue
but not that there's anything wrong with
that I mean as long as you're okay with
it you can put the game on hard or
something you could turn it up to hard
mode if you wanted
increase the challenge a little bit
are you serious
he turned around right when I
[Music]
that is crazy
we were right there
all right
Rebellion
okay let's see if there's another way in
we can just keep making our way around
like couldn't we just fly fig no
you don't have a broom with you buddy
all right well
maybe I miss
oh no oh there it is again oh my gosh
there it is again I want to get away bro
please let me get on my broom but we're
on a mission we can't
I'm gonna watch it until it just like
fades
oh
foreign
that is like one of the coolest things
in this game
oh my gosh that is so cool
helping out all the little hamlets in
the various side quests
nice
yeah I've checked out those windows Yep
oh you can name the owl by your bed did
not know that
can't stop Red Rocks for a million okay
that was I did not expect that to happen
right there
dude that Dragon wait does he not even
know I'm here
oh no they exactly what's happening from
him
exposure
nice fig let's go dude
I know man
that's the second time we've seen the
dragon but the the first time we saw him
we were on we were on a hippogriff but I
just I was so
Frozen in shock I couldn't believe it
was happening I should have went after
him just like see what would happen how
long can you follow him does he attack I
have no idea
I don't know
all right we might be able to make that
oh let's make sure there's not anything
out here
we can grab
doesn't look like it
if I don't know
I wouldn't have to dig if you oh they're
both here to bring me the child we
wouldn't need the child if you hadn't
sent a dragon to retrieve the container
I spent months and countless Ministry
favors tracking oh he sent the Dragon
you let them board the courage my
options were limited once I knew I can't
believe they're both here only be on my
reach of that infernal School
have you not acquired enough
under my family home allowed me
you are here only because you are
descended from a keeper
amazingly become valuable we had an
agreement I will share with you the
power that I discovered if you locate
the stores of magic that are yet to be
found
so
unless you want another demonstration of
my power oh I wish they would just fight
right now
bring me the child what if we just
stepped out right now we're like I'm
here
let's do it
let's go let's go right now come on big
we could take him
we could take them no they're digging
for stores of magic
he knows about the keepers I say we go
after him right now
Professor Rookwood said that you'd
understand more once you complete the
next trial let's get into that castle
Trail here
okay can we go back soon yeah so did
they just leave
I think would left too
oh we got some treasure
oh come on
special words
many special words you want me to pass
on to your mum
oh no I'm on the wrong spell
okay there we go
no
oh no my screen's messing up again right
now
what is that move
[Music]
oh they're level 27 man
like talk about the worst possible time
for my
screen to mess up
oh there's a guy up there
yeah
let's get you down
oh it was too far
boom I can break the shield so
potatoes
dude I just think the combat is so fun
in this game
oh just in time we nailed him with it
right before that spell hit
I just love the combat man I love it
hey guys welcome thank you for the new
subscribers
foreign
I've been wondering that too dearly I've
been wondering that too I never saw it
in my
so in the session that Ben and I we
played the same section of the game
I never saw it revelio
which is really interesting to me I
don't know
if it was the way we went about about
the mission or what I'm really not sure
how it happened
oh wait there's still people here
find a very interesting Rookwood named
his gang after a fairly harmless snake
wait have we have we seen the name of
rookwood's gang yet I don't even know if
I've seen that yet or if I did I
probably just didn't even
didn't even register with me all right
I've already forgotten it one of the two
all right looks like there's still some
things around here
and still some enemies
hot dog what's up how's it going
oh the ash whiners right right right
right yes
thank you Alex yeah it's it's really fun
it is really fun I'm enjoying it a lot
so far
okay wait there was something here I was
gonna say there's something over this
way
I don't even know if we need to be
sneaking around anymore but
dude this place is huge right here
all right I think we're good
I thought I heard them talking though
but
all right so you can't open that
Rebellion
I did see something over here okay
there's more enemies there
but I think they're outside
excuse me I think they're outside I
don't think we need to worry about them
now
those might be the ones that we just
completely bypassed snuck by
why not the best let's score runes
spores horn serpents why ashwiners
oh maybe because the eggs match their
aesthetic
foreign
are you doing more let's play for your
evil round
oh yeah yeah Shelby I'll be I plan on
streaming this game a lot
we're actually Gonna Be Live on Twitch
tomorrow just to do another round of the
drops
since people are really interested in
getting those
so we'll be over there tomorrow
sometime in the am not really sure what
time yeah I was thinking trying to do
around 10 but depends on
how late I actually after this I'm gonna
have to uh I gotta edit a video for
tomorrow
oh yeah he totally seems like it sounds
cool
revelio
man this is a really large area
I was not expecting this
but I mean it's like a main main mission
we just met
or just met up with the two primary
antagonists
anything to do over here
nope all right nothing just a little
area to explore
Michael what's up how do you get it in
game you got the drop it's not my game
okay
so you gotta go to hogwartslegacy.com go
to the top of the screen
there's an area there that says twitch
drops click on that
and you have to make sure that you have
also claimed the drop on Hogwarts Legacy
so it's not just claiming it on Twitch
claim it on Hogwarts Legacy
and then after you do that restart your
game and it should be there
all right we need to get over into that
area where all these blue things are yep
this way
oh no dude fig
how did you just did he just operate
down there
oh come on you got this come on just
jump you got it buddy there we go
all right
yeah whatever you did dude
oh yeah the
you have to hit all of them okay so
let's make sure there's nothing else
down here that we need to get
oh we missed that chest or maybe we're
gonna we're gonna get to that soon
yeah no problem Michael no problem
hope that works for you I know a lot of
people been confused on it
Patrick what's up dude welcome back
dumb was like these before I need to
find all of them then cast up them
quickly in succession revelio is that
not what I just did fig
oh you just need to do one at a time
okay I thought you had to like kind of
power them up
oh no gaming console
I'm so sorry to hear that
so sorry to hear that
oh
losing a pet man it's tough it's tough
yeah I don't know what we will do when
our we our dog Luna we basically call
her our firstborn she like we had her
before we even had kids
very sorry to hear that
maybe maybe the stream and
maybe gaming something can take your
mind off of it for a little bit ahead of
us
see where they lead
yeah good to have you back Patrick good
to have you
how far have you made it I feel like
everybody's passed me up so tonight I
was just like you know what
lumos I've got to do some story missions
I've got to crank out some story
missions
oh internal bleeding stage four cancer
I'm so sorry dude
okay what is that
no
why are they still here
Brian Rock said there's more to be found
and if he's right about that it may or
may not be located here
wherever it is we need to find it before
they do wait I thought you said that is
that portrait
oh we need to find the portrait dude
that's crazy that it's right there
Rebellion
all right so we gotta find the portrait
so wait randrock's power has nothing to
do with the ancient magic I still think
it does
I still think it does you've been
watching streams all day and pumping up
communities
nice Patrick and you're so far behind
man see I even had a head start but
people are just like blasting through
this game
oh Rebellion
further than Miranda
well who knows because she does just
let's plays right so she could have
several films that we don't know about
oh there's a portrait there's the
portrait
I don't know what that means
break down when you see your caller that
you say oh gaming console I'm so sorry
oh revelio
that's just tough
PC you're still waiting for it to
release
what
oh are you talking about the regular
like the standard edition on Friday
oh here we go here's something over here
quidditch goggles I actually think we
found two upgrades
that we should look at
all right we can go here
oh okay we can put that one on but we
lose the uh I don't even really use
venomous tentaculous
don't even really use them
all right but I just want to go back to
invisible on that
see if we got a better hat nope
a better scarf
oh we do
oh and hold on increased damage from
ancient Magic
let's go
yeah that's a good one to apply right
there
oh and that oh dude that
except for kind of the green part on the
back that sort of goes with the Merlin
I don't know it even it still kind of
fits even with that but I'm just gonna
go without it
okay that's an upgrade
oh dude that's actually pretty nice
cloak right there
and I'm gonna Stick With Merlin though
for now
all right and this one
not an upgrade okay
challenges what do we got in here
oh we unlocked this one let's go great
trait recipe reward protego shielding
one
don't know what that does but I'm
curious
I am curious
hey Leo how's it going
you're a little worried about Ellen you
don't think she's coming back
hey she was here she was here she's
still popping in I think occasionally
still keeping an eye on things
occasionally honestly like of all the
mods she's been by far the one who I've
seen the most tonight honestly
but no it's I see I told you
no it's all good I told the mods like
when the game comes out it was like
seriously take take your time and play
the game play the game do not feel like
you have to be here at every stream
please please we've all been waiting on
this game for such a long time make sure
you enjoy it
oh dude this room is so cool
oh is that a phoenix up there it is and
it said Rookwood is looking for a
phoenix
all right let's talk to the portrait now
so Rookwood the goblins and dog Wizards
who vote Jenny Sears here too yep that's
right broken open some sort of Ginny and
L one I've seen a lot of Elwyn too
things are more dire than I could have
imagined and Jenny I saw Nico for a
little bit a goblin in his vault was
wielding a powerful Magic
somehow learned
it cannot be and sir I think I saw oh no
Dylan May beeper ran Rock used the term
Christy was here too there's no sense
how did
we shall discuss this later right now
you must complete the next trial oh dude
Charles is panicked
window shooting again I'm live tomorrow
tomorrow we're gonna do a twitch stream
Patrick because
um I'm under I want to do the drops
again some people are still looking to
get those
so we're gonna do a twitch stream and
then Friday I'm I'm not sure yet about
Friday if I'm gonna stream or not and I
don't know my plans for the weekend yet
I got I've got so many videos I need to
make honestly so I want to want to knock
out some videos and then we'll kind of
figure out what the next streaming plan
is from there but yeah definitely on
Twitch tomorrow
depending on how late I stay up
Auden or Auden welcome thank you for
stopping by
Paula loves LFC welcome Paula I feel
like we I feel like we deserve to know
more first
he's like this makes no sense how did we
shall discuss no yeah you should tell us
surely I've proven myself in light of
what's happened perhaps you should be
alone but I'm asking but Power you stand
to wield must first be fully understood
the trials will ensure that power
without knowledge is dangerous indeed
okay in the wrong hands we will simply
have to okay wait ran Rock and my
unfortunate news I think okay very well
Professor tell me where I need to go I
shall reveal the path Professor fig must
leave you now
God ah Professor fig must leave you now
wait is he doing this to fake oh I was
like what the heck
how is he interacting with him through a
portrait
[Music]
all right hold on just just making sure
there's nothing else here
dude I love these missions it's about to
get so cool
where are we going next where are we
going if I could
I shall awake
what year do I arrival at the map
chamber all right we'll see you there
foreign
been a crazy day Patrick
's dude it is like
it was the most popular I think it broke
a twitch record the other day
I think it broke a twitch record
oh I didn't see the link Owen but um
um gaming console was just they
Unfortunately they just lost their dog
so I'm not sure what the what the link
was though
Elwyn is actually a dog trainer gaming
console
hey happy birthday officially 18. let's
go
yeah I feel like 18 and 21 they're like
the last big ones after that it's just
like eh
eh
don't really want to think about as I'm
getting older
oh you're posting a pic hey if you if
you want to share pics of pets we do
have um we do have a section for that in
the Discord
if you do exclamation point Discord
I don't know if you're a Discord person
but we have uh
we have a place for that there
all right I guess I don't think there's
anything we could do over there
although these little like
hope that's not important
not even sure what ancient magic Temple
we're in here but
is it right here
wait where is it
I feel like we're right on it
oh there it is
yeah we have a
we have a section in the Discord all for
sharing uh pictures of
of our pets well not even our pets
really it can be our pets but doesn't
have to be
all right what just changed in here I
think it's got this like reddish tint to
it now
see some sort of book or scroll over
here revelio oh no that's the thing I
broke
all right
no
wait why are you moving
okay that's weird
excuse me
it's not touching you oh it's like the
spell effect though
oh that's so interesting
the effect from the spell
okay we can't do it on that
oh let's see
wait what you can't move this wait we
just did move this one
by using this
I don't know if this is intended or not
but it's working
wait was that all you're supposed to do
was that it
soundtrack what's up soundtrack welcome
hey I appreciate the kind words
is that how you say it
revelio
been without a dog for almost 12 years
excited to move so you can get one again
oh are you about to move Patrick
hey good night soundtrack have a good
one
wait I feel I I feel like there's a lot
in this area we did not
see or explore Rebellion
okay like what it
why is this room here
so fascinated by this
oh thank you
Adam I hate to hear that you're going
through a rough time blocking the path
but it I'm I'm glad that the stream can
take your mind off of it at least a
little bit
hope whatever you're going through Works
itself out
oh wait I just missed what my character
said
there was a chest oh my gosh I knew it
I knew it
okay wait so the last one I was able to
oh wait there's a chest right there
I'm gonna be honest with you guys like
all of these that I've navigated
I still don't really understand exactly
what's going on
it's like it's sort of like a
multiple Dimension kind of thing
foreign
so clearly we're gonna need that
am I supposed to go back over here
so
oh and I did I say congrats on the job
Patrick I can't remember if I did or not
congrats that's great
yeah there's something like something
really nice about having having that
security for sure
okay this looks like some
okay definitely something you can
interact with there
but
okay let's see if I pass through here
what now it's a chest
oh dude I am so fascinated by this okay
so then we go back through
where'd the block go
please
hold up
I should have the block here why is my
block still not do I have to go back
through it this way
what
oh my goodness
bruh I'm so lost right now
I am so lost
see this is what I meant like I have no
idea what's actually happening
where did my where did my extra block go
[Music]
okay it's red
now it's blue what color is it on this
side
dude where did my block go
it was in this realm right here
oh and I bet you there's something over
here too
all right all right all right all right
all right all right hold on
Leviosa
but I can still see like the bigger one
what
Kathy welcome by the way hold on I saw
people welcoming Kathy new here enjoying
the live not a game or just a Harry
Potter fan still waiting on your game
from GameStop oh my goodness
I can't believe the shipping's taking
that long
sorry to hear that Kathy but I'm glad
you uh enjoy the content enjoy the
streams welcome in welcome in
Ryan glad to hear that glad to hear that
Ryan
oh no another pet no
odd and I don't think it will we had to
put my baby my cat down because she had
leukemi she was only 13.
oh that's two pets tonight
oh my goodness I'm so sorry guys
there was a chest on the higher level
too maybe you can Leviosa the block and
climb it
hey welcome back fishy
if you get too stuck yeah you could load
a previous save
hey have a good one elwin see you later
all right and then we also have the fact
that this does something too
when we do this right here
but we have no idea what
I thought we'd figured it out for a
second
okay we could try we could try the
levioso on this
oh no
no
what no
oh no now where in the world did it put
me
what
all right
okay yeah now we're back here now we're
back here
all right this is where we were
this is where we were
here
oh you nailed it Ryan and Patrick with
the Super Chat
oh my goodness like at the same time
thank you guys thank you for the Super
Chat Patrick yeah so I was like this is
doing something okay so just one hit
with that and that spins all right
okay so we went in here that is how we
got
that right there
I mean I see where we were supposed to
go
like we're supposed to go over there
with that guy but I'm just like so
I'm so fascinated by this whole room in
here
why is that still showing that the
shimmering of the larger one
I and I should have another box I should
have a box right here that's just a
normal sized box
what the heck now it's a chest over here
what is happening
bro
this doesn't make sense
we we've lost the previous blocks I mean
all I want to do I just want to see
what's up here
I wanted to see what's up there
and now like there's a chest over here
that we could have gotten apparently
all right let's go back through it that
way
oh wait and then what if we
okay we don't want to go in there
all right what if we go through
okay so there's no there's no chest over
there
what if we go through here
okay there it is there it is there it is
there it is all right
the block is back
all right this is the one we had
originally
this is the one we had originally
and there's our large one
now we can levioso this
can jump that there you go
oh
why can you not make that jump
oh dude you can make that jump
a gaming console very sorry for your
loss
appreciate you stopping by
double jump right
all right so
okay there's that one all right
and then we wanted to go through this
way
okay now the little one's gone again
it's over here
oh I'm trying it again oh wait we didn't
have it all the way to the edge
okay
dude watch there not even be anything up
here
oh no we can't move it in
we can't move it in this realm
we need to go oh wait but wait then what
is this dude
okay just takes you back into that
little area
which we don't need that
all right all right all right there we
go now it's a chest again what in the
world
this is so crazy
all right now we can move this
dude it's gonna be so funny when we get
up here and there's just like nothing
even worth no I didn't mean to do that
okay that is at the very edge
all right
the very edge
all right and then let's see yeah I
think you definitely have to levioso it
take Inception right a tree within a
dream
okay
okay you can oh and there is a chest
this better be like the best item in the
game
the freaking Elder Wand needs to be in
here
48 coins
48 coins you know what it's the
satisfaction though the satisfaction we
found we found it dude
48 coins
oh and there's another chest though
all that for 48 coins
I don't even care dude I don't even care
it was the challenge the fact that we
could say we did it now
all right now this
oh
another chest all right 38 coins okay
we're we're going the wrong direction
that was
dearly oh man I love it
I love it
the dad jokes are welcome here
they are welcome here
all right so now it's like we're back in
the main room see I need a way to be
like in here
and Trigger the
like the realm shift
you see like right now it's not even
active we have to go into this
nah you can't Mount anything inside the
dungeons like your broom or your uh
hippogriff or anything
oh wait I just realized one possibility
one possibility to get that chest
it was worth a try right
laughs
yeah we just have to get it now you guys
know this right
wait where's the little one the little
one's gone okay wait to get the little
one
all right all right all right yeah yes
all right come on out over here
okay stay right there
all right now we go back
and
oh no you can't stand on it now
I don't want to go through the gate yet
come on oh come on you dude I know it's
I know it's some big spikes you can make
this jump
oh come on
oh that's weak that's weak sauce
that's that's weak
you can make that you could definitely
you could oh you could totally make that
jump
it's only baked that job
oh man
let's see if it works like in this realm
because if it does like this might be I
wonder if this will be game breaking
hold on I should save right here
I'm very curious to see if this will
actually work
let's see settings
save game
uh let's see what my oldest one right
there
any other blocks you can use I don't
think so I've not found any
if this works though dude like I don't
think there's
I don't think there's a way out of here
oh it doesn't
just like a completely invisible wall
all right
yeah so I mean I think the idea is that
you need to move it
like that's like that's a chest right
there but I already opened that one
oh come on I know right
all right I'm ready I think I'm ready to
move on because
yeah
I think we move on
all right let's do this I love fighting
these guys I'm gonna go and put on
Expelliarmus
oh my there's a bunch
foreign
right there that's so fun dude
save my ancient magic for the big one
thanks for the arms
all the big boys coming in he's coming
in no
good finger
yeah let's take out all the smaller ones
first
all right now we're ready for you yeah
just just done
just done
that ancient magic took took him down
quite a bit
took him down quite a bit rebelio
I love doing that's my favorite thing to
do though is the Expelliarmus and then
the ancient magic throw
previously known as a pugno
okay yeah I mean go through this
obviously
Mayas can someone give me this game I
truly desire it
foreign
well hello there treasure
47 coins now
all right well we might as well see
where this leads revelio
oh son
there's another one to play around with
here
all right so
I mean are we supposed to like pass it
through the realm
is that gonna help us though
oh no way if this is actually what
you're supposed to do
like and then then can I keep it
no don't fall
no come back
go back
on the far wall no that sort of thing is
repositioning it should totally make you
it should totally make you die if you
fall off like that
it should totally make you die
that was pretty funny all the same
though
oh my goodness I didn't even hear what
my character just said what did he says
now where is it just gone now like
there's got to be a way to make
way to make oh
wait wait wait wait so
now I just gotta know though what was
the point of that block
what was the point of that block
I mean it's gone and I don't think I
need it to progress
I don't think I needed to progress
I guess we're about to find out
it's like why is that not hitting him
almost as good as playing
that's what I love to hear
all right yeah yeah I know I know I know
ancient magic and all that
oh come on that should totally give you
something cool
that should totally give you something
cool
no no no this is not a Merlin puzzle the
Merlin puzzles are really uh
way simpler than this
okay
all right so we could go back that way
but I don't think we're supposed to
all right so we've got this large
column here
we also have a treasure
oh oh okay all right we're doing this
oh you can use the eggs to hit him
that's awesome
foreign
did I see another one over here
what why is he invisible oh no ways in
the freaking other Realm
no
that was sick
oh my gosh that was so cool
foreign
oh my goodness that was awesome
Rebellion
oh dude like the realization oh and wait
there's something up there too
the realization of like hold on a second
am I actually gonna have to fight this
guy while he's invisible no wait realm
shift
realm shift
oh my gosh there's so many hold on hold
on I'm not ready for this yet I'm not
ready I don't want to go there yet
okay this feels like the way I'm
supposed to go
foreign
oh wait I don't think I can get back I
can't get back to that Realm
because I was gonna try and get the
wait what just happened it's gone now
all right so we can either
you can either do this here
just quoting Assassin's Creed I broke
the game
like you could do that okay hold on I
think this right here
let me see if I'm right
yes okay that
reactivates
nope wrong spell
oh come on AIM at the right side wait
can we not move this
oh
can we just the Pulsa Maybe
okay nothing to accio there
YouTube keeps going back to top chat
instead of live chat oh can you on mine
I have it set up to live but I don't
know that might just be my view or
something
revelio
and I still want that chest back there
too man
see it's like we need to get that
we need to get this
over here
right here
all right let's pass through
okay this is one of the realms
can I move it
nope
uh yes we did meet poppy yep
okay I just have to see where this goes
oh that's where we came from all right
good good good good good good okay
the the wobbling stairs like that threw
me off I was like wait is that where I'm
supposed to go yeah it didn't make any
sense that I didn't have to
first do something with this see it's
like I didn't go through any other realm
right there though but something that I
just like walking too far away it reset
you may be bad
don't be sad exactly Patrick
wow making us feel great here
I may be back sad face
oh no technical difficulties oh
tell him I can relate we've been having
all sorts of issues lately
and man I mean Hogwarts Legacy can
relate too
it happens oh there it is guys
there it is didn't see it earlier
didn't see it earlier
all right so now the question is this
way or this way
this way oh my gosh this is insane dude
this is insane this is some deep like
really deep thought
right here
okay you know what I think
I think we can do this right here
oh my gosh
big brain chat big brain
zodiac I play too much of this game
since it came out cannot get enough
zodiac everybody passed me up dude
everybody passed me up so tonight it was
like dude this is gonna be an all-out
gameplay stream
this really is like trippy
all right I think we can leave it here
and then
I don't even think we need to tr oh wait
we do have to travel back through
oh my gosh no no
it's even crazier than that
it's even crazier than that Patrick
because what we have to do possible to
pull one of those blocks through the
archway
you think retro no actually I think
there might be another way
I'm gonna see I'm gonna see if this
works
here's what I was gonna do
here's what I was like I was gonna I was
gonna accio it from here
wingardium it
I mean I guess this will work
okay I guess you have to push it
straight through
I was gonna try to go around
but now is that okay wait
yes right there
and then
oh no that's not close enough
let's go presents I've got presents
dream and plays with another Super Chat
just back I'm back just went on a side
mission binge got turned around so much
in this trial was stuck for like dude
this one is crazy
thank you for the Super Chat by the way
all right oh it's like I can't
I can't reach it far enough
maybe maybe I'll have to pull on the
block out through the archway I can
place it where it can be climbed on
while on the other side of the archway
wow I didn't think of that retro
no I totally did but I was
okay I mean this was my original plan
was just to sit it right here but
then you go back through
there's no way to get up there
it is taller wait can I make that jump
hold on
huh can we make this jumper yeah I
didn't think so but wait can we Leviosa
no we cannot
thank you for the Super Chat dreaming
thank you
you have to turn the platform you're on
yeah we
you're probably right yeah like if we
have to
okay and then the question is it this
way
or the other way
turn Arch as you're on the platform
all right so hold on we've got a big
we got to work backwards in right
because don't I have to pick this back
up
yeah I do I've gotta
oh no not accio
we're gonna have to pick it back up
all right what
okay
just go until you finish no I'm not
gonna go that far
I'm not gonna go that far but
I wanted I wanted to really make some
good progress tonight
okay
all right hold on hold on
don't help me
okay so you can do that
but I need it back where it's
yeah yeah I need to get back over here
no no no no no I need to have it where
oh
I can't think it's too late for this
oh my gosh
I need to have it where
I had it wait what do you mean team
yeah I mean I know I can jump up here
I was up here earlier oh and then all I
have to literally all I have to do is
this no way
oh my gosh dude it's always easier than
I'm trying to make it out
but dude my character was totally he
said something like maybe I can make
stuff
make it go through the uh
through the portal or something
I guess you don't have to do that
foreign
oh my gosh Rebellion all right either
way that was cool that was fun
it's crazy bizarre as it was it was very
interesting
revelio doesn't really help you a lot in
this either
does not really help you a lot
hey Ry welcome back oh yeah we've just
been
it's been cranking out the story stuff
tonight
even though we've been getting like
really interested in the random little
spots where we can go and look for
chests in this dungeon or whatever you
call it
revelio
uh oh
wait wait wait oh no
all right we've got all sorts of
hot spots right here but we also have
these enemies
I feel like we should fight
I mean if they're visible oh
oh my gosh I'm so sick
foreign
that is my favorite move in the game to
do I love it the moment they showed that
in the trailer and it's just as fun to
do in the actual game
it is just as fun you got stuck here so
many times
nastily exhaustive Wizards Wizarding
tests I know right like see I'm so
tempted to
I mean I feel like we're supposed to
activate this right here but I'm just
like well what's this over here
what's this right here then
what's this this looks like the end
okay you guys know you guys know
if you've been hanging out watching the
stream you you already know like I have
to
I have to experiment with this I have to
see what happens here
all right where is it where is it it's
right here
okay we've got a chest up at the top
beautiful
now they're spinning
oh
excuse me
I think I got it I think I got it I
think you have to do
oh we gotta get the right spell ready
we got to get it ready
we just wingardium the chest
oh my goodness that was so cool
that was so cool
I don't think there's anything else up
there
that was sick
okay now we can proceed
my curiosity has been satisfied
from some pretty dapper uh hairy-esque
spectacles
yeah there's some good ones there's some
Dumbledore Dumbledore ones too I was
rocking those for a while actually
see I knew this place was gonna be fun I
knew it was
I want to fight some more of those
Knights dude those might be my favorite
enemies to fight revelio
let's fight like three of them
some giant ones oh they just gave us
five Wigan weld
you know what that means any any game
where they give you like oh here's some
health
here's a bunch of potions here's a bunch
of healing items
because you're gonna need it
all right let's do it I'm ready oh yeah
here we go oh no
oh this is so epic
so now
I've got
an invisible guy out
oh he's going down right here
all right so we got him we got him we
got him
all right let's take care of all the
ones in oh no I'm about to die
let's take care of all the ones in this
realm first
just jumped
I could do that all day
that is the coolest move in the game
places
I love it
oh man this guy is Wrecking me
we gotta get over to his realm
oh hello sir
yeah what now buddy
[Music]
no freaking way we did accio we did the
protego
and still got the ancient magic throw on
him
okay he's in the other realm we gotta go
back we gotta go back
no wait where the heck is this guy
hold on do we have to like go back
through this way
whoa hold on what's Happening chat
okay why can we not find this dude
there he is he had to go through the red
side
freaking epic game with the Super Chat
oh no
oh my gosh sorry Gabe
I thought we were done
thought we were done game
Oh wrong spell
there we go
who else is shooting at me
ancient Magic
oh dude he has so much help
oh my gosh but we gotta back up we gotta
back up
[Music]
I guess I should just keep firing these
at him
all right still purple
oh we just Frozen
I don't know it would actually worked
oh we switched the yellow on us
ancient Magic
go dude let's go
Gringo Iglesias how about an incendio
for you too
oh we gotta back up I forgot
who is shooting me
I think it's a minion that I can't see
come back to purple
well it's something way over there
way over there
ancient magic all right we got him below
half
oh back up back up back up back up back
up
yeah this is like
oh it's part of his power okay okay
oh he does have another
oh my gosh dude
I was like okay I'm kind of getting used
to this I feel like he needs another
move
he he needs another move
and then he pulls out a freaking
whatever you call these things a mace
[Music]
oh I did it too early
oh that's part of his power too
oh no
I almost missed it
almost missed that one
culture
places
oh he's still going dude like
what do you think about 15 Health left
15 percent
oh I should have reflected that back at
him
I mean supervised doing a little bit of
damage so I might as well keep doing
this
as long as I can time it
I don't think expelled oh expelliarma
still a little bit
places
the glaciers confringo
let's be doing pretty well
all right I bet he's getting ready to do
his
not yet
okay
accio
oh oh I knew he was about to switch it
up
I feel like we need to finish him with
magic attack
oh my gosh like top
top three maybe the maybe the most epic
moment in the game so far
oh wow that was awesome
can you ex billions the weapon he has I
tried expelliarms a couple times that
would have been oh dude that would have
been really interesting to try
if I had done it right when he was
swinging
oh my gosh what a fight
Gabe okay finally getting to Gabe Super
Chat
game I'm so sorry we just got an epic
moment right there
finally getting to play for the first
time right now you become one of my
favorite creators thank you for covering
the game so amazingly Gabe thank you for
the support dude
thank you for the support hope you enjoy
the game it is epic I don't know I hope
you weren't spoiled too much I don't
know if you wanted to see that or not
but
wow that fight was super fun
that was super fun
Morning Star that's right that's right
I gotta scroll up now and I'll see what
you guys were saying Boss by incoming oh
yeah you knew it was happening
I was thinking that too for a second
Patrick I was like maybe it's another
invisible minion somewhere
dude did I like my uh
somehow during the fight my hood my hood
came off
or I must have uh disabled it
come on dude we rocking the Merlin Hood
let's go
can you push into the veil into the
other realm I was wondering about that
too during that other fight
crucia
hey we try to keep it fam family
friendly here or Hey but
I don't have crucio anyway
I don't have crucio yet probably not
going to learn it on this playthrough
mace FL yeah mace flail Morningstar I
guess all of them work
yeah I'm on normal still
I definitely want to do a hard play
through though
definitely want to do a hard play
through
glad that I play on the story
yeah like did he knock the hood off yeah
yeah I'm loving I'm loving the Merlin
gear
uh dude that was just crazy that I was
like okay this is getting a little bit
repetitive
and the SEC like the second that I said
I wish he had another move
he busts out another move
I almost wish he had like a third
I wish there was like one more thing
that he he did to like switch it up even
more
but I realize they're not making they're
not trying to make like a Souls game
here so
regardless though that was epic man that
was epic yeah Nico that was the coolest
one by far that I've seen yet
making sure there's not anything I'm
supposed to do in this area
oh my gosh dude that whole section was
incredible
all right I guess we're just supposed to
go back now
uh Professor Baxter I will when I get my
collector's edition yeah
so
you guys are here watching the stream
I'll give you a little sneak peek of
what's gonna happen
so I ordered a collector's edition right
well I think
I think I'm about like 95 sure that WB
is actually hooking me up with a with a
Collector's Edition from them
which is like super awesome very nice of
them to do that
however
um
I can't like I can't give that one away
so I think I might do a giveaway of my
collector's edition
oh my gosh what was that
yeah I think I might do a giveaway for
my collectors
if if it all works out if it all works
out so on my like my collectors that I
ordered was for PS5
and so then when they told me this was a
possibility I was like well I guess I
should do a different version
so I asked for the uh
I said if you have the PC one I'll take
the PC but if not
I'll take another I'll take a PS5
so I don't know what they're sending me
yet or when they're sending it or
anything like that but
so yeah you guys get a little sneak
preview
I'm probably going to be doing a
giveaway but I would announce it like I
would give people plenty of time to
enter and stuff it would just be like a
you know just like an online thing you
fill out I've been looking into that
gleam.io website dude this this whole
room
sorry to just get com go completely off
topic but this whole room is amazing
oh he can't buy it anymore Patrick
unless I don't know you might want to
check like Amazon GameStop they might
have a few that either were returned or
people uh like cancel to pre-order
something
yeah
I mean I'll be honest like the the price
of the collector's edition is it's it's
too high
no it's it's overpriced for sure but
it's like I actually think the items in
it are cool there's just like not it's
just not a lot for what you what you're
paying
it's like 300 bucks and you get this
like it's like a it's a it's a plastic
book
and then there's like you plug it into
the wall and the wand kind of like
floats on it it hovers it's got one of
those magnet magnet things inside which
I think that is cool and then it comes
with a steel case
and then you get a special Kelpie robe
and then all the other stuff you get
with the deluxe
but it's like 300.
so it's like if that was 200
I would I would still feel it's like
it's a slightly overpriced but I would
feel you know okay but yeah 300 is a
little much
but I'm just like I might as well keep
mine and give it away to you guys for
all the crazy support so if it all works
out like I said WB just reached out and
said hey whatever you're interested I
said yeah
but they haven't like I haven't gotten
any confirmation that it's been like
sent or anything
why was it I informed about this it was
a crazy day like when the pre-orders
went up it was a crazy day
a lot of people who were trying did not
get one I don't know how I got one I was
actually at work and just happened to
see I was watching James expecto Goes
live stream
and some people were in his chat were
saying like GameStop and so I went over
there and just got one in
all right
but now as I'm thinking about that like
I wonder if I'll be able to get the
Kelpie robe
on the PS5
oh no I'll have to have to figure that
out all right Charles Rookwood memories
let's do this
let's do it
I'm ready for a big Epic
story moment oh pensive time baby let's
go
I was so hoping they would use like
tenses as a mechanic in this game
come in
foreign
we are all most intrigued to hear I feel
like she's gonna turn
gonna turn
I've something to show you I go dark
these are my colleagues from Hogwarts
father hasn't spoken since my brother
died
oh that's right I thought she said my
guy too I confirmed that which I've
always believed
that we have the power to take away pain
uh oh
here's a Dora
take away pain
I don't know if that's a good thing
though
people need to feel pain
this is Uncharted magic is Adora
you can only see what has been sealed in
the jar and we do not know what power
that may hold that's the power ran Rock
the traces of that magic are different
from what I've seen before it's the red
thank you
wait did it actually help him though
oh that's
super interesting
so it actually
oh man I thought it was gonna like
backfire
I thought it was gonna backfire because
if you think about I didn't even know
this was do you guys know this is a real
thing there's apparently some people who
they have this I don't know what it's
even called but they can't feel
pain
which at first you think oh that'd be
awesome right but no like you can't feel
like if you have your hand on something
hot you wouldn't know that it's hot
so you could just literally be getting
burned
and have no idea that it was happening
yeah it's super dangerous
so I guess I guess what they were going
for there is not that like that dude
will never feel pain again
it's more just she's like taking away
the current pain that he feels
and then he still but who knows there's
probably going to be more to that more
to that story I'd be shocked if there
wasn't more um
repercussions from that
and clearly I think that's the magic ran
rock is tapping into
probably in these future memories we're
gonna get to see how
it gets loose or something I don't know
all right back to the map chamber we go
yeah it could be like the mint like
she's removing the mental pain for him
all right Charles boy do we have a story
for you man
oh wait they already know this because
they were there how could you not tell
us this you literally knew how it is
good to see you again
Professor Rookwood told me about what
happened at Rookwood Castle oh my gosh
we've been going four and a half hours
circumstances in which we find ourselves
it is most fortunate that someone so
competent is following this path we told
you to be trusted I shall keep the
second artifact safe as you've advised
good are you ready to move on
uh oh we can ask what it is adorable
what was the glowing strand that Isadora
pulled from her father's chest it was
pain you will understand
as you complete the trials
oh come on she we we know it was pain
they said it was pain I'm ready for
whatever comes next Rookwood I don't
know if I trust you dude don't know
don't know if I trust you introduce
former Hogwarts headmistress Nev
Fitzgerald
how do you do I must say that I was not
entirely surprised to learn that a
student had been completing the trials
I've always believed Hogwarts students
capable of anything they said there
might be dearly thank you Professor it's
a pleasure to meet you as well I am
certain that you are more than capable
of completing my trial however I must
first how shall I say prepare the
location of your next trial
we trust your judgment Professor
Fitzgerald you should know better than
anyone how to manage the inconvenience
of well
then glorious and exasperating
Headmaster indeed I should
I shall confirm that everything is in
order immediately oh
of course oh
Professor Fitzgerald needs some time to
clear the way forward until then I think
you shall continue to hone your magic if
you learn more about ran Rock and Victor
rookwood's activities in the meantime
please let us know very well Professor
you guys remember that little scene they
teased
with the book in the headmaster's office
I think that's gonna be related to her
trial how many more people do we have by
the way okay we just got her and then
one more
you got the Merlin cloak drop okay sane
yes
um so what you have to do is you have to
go to hogwartslexi.com click on Twitch
drops at the top
and make sure that you have activated it
there so not only do you have to
activate it on Twitch confirm it there
you also have to activate it on the
Hogwarts Legacy site then
and there'll be a little button like
where you can click it
then reboot your game and it should pop
right away should pop
I know I know continue to hone my magic
you do learn quickly hopefully you will
soon hear from lodgok as well and we
shall learn how he fared with the helmet
well done today as always we shall speak
again soon
we shall speak again soon
oh cut scene time oh are we in Winter
now
oh my gosh let's go
oh I'm gonna be taking so many
screenshots in winter
so many screenshots in winter
my favorite season like visually
and we wake back up in the common room
we wake back up in the common room
Clement hello there welcome
yeah try that scene see if that works
that was awesome right that was awesome
Panda yes
Colton I know so beautiful all right
let's read our mail
all right I don't think we have any okay
yeah we don't have anything new all
right
okay you know what I have to do though
like I have to
I have to go out
and I have to check out
we have to just like fly around in this
we have to fly around
oh my goodness it's absolutely glorious
has to do with you oh let's go that's
that's that's the mission that we played
that we got to play early
I think I'm guessing
I have been asked to teach you the
exploding challenge
wait how do I read that letter
I wanted to read that
I think they go into your inventory said
love letter
whose Love Letter did we just pick up
oh there it is
my dearest up Apollonia would you care
to join me for a picnic I know you enjoy
a good Cornish pasty almost as much as
you enjoy a good mystery see you soon I
hope yours Richard
oh who Could That bee Richard and
Apollonia
Richard I'm trying to think of any
Richard that we would know from the
series
got you wanted to catch up
dude after that last mission
all right I just have to sail around for
a minute Patrick oh my gosh Patrick were
you here when we saw the uh the Dragon
guys look at oh my gosh dude
just
that shot of Hogwarts right there
hold on let's get back up here
slow down now let's get back up here
I need to race now my friend
white dragon dude you gotta
when I in the Stream you gotta go back
and Rewind
it was right before actually it happened
twice
right after I do if you can go back and
you find where I rescue Highway and
we're flying away on highway so high
Wing is the white hippogriff
right after we completed that
just this seemingly unscripted moment
with a dragon I don't I don't want to
ruin it I don't want to ruin it you need
to you need to watch you need to watch
it
but then
we saw another Dragon like a little bit
later
I lost my mind
just lost my mind
okay I just have to like
oh my goodness
what a glorious shot
all right let's fly
this one quicker
faster
dude I could just fly around here
oh did you figure it out fishy nice
Richard jackdaw
foreign
and you got the music going too
[Music]
I need to take some of these without
I need to turn off just completely turn
off the hood and also when you're taking
screenshots make sure you enable
Fidelity mode like if you want the best
possible screenshots like I'm on
performance right now
because I like the faster frame rate
watch this guys if you haven't seen me
flying the hippogriff yet
they seriously added so many amazing
little touches to this
somebody was asking earlier like can you
fly close to the water
all right tell me if you guys remember
this scene from the movies
watch this watch this watch this
[Music]
right right you remember that you
remember that
I just like I'm just in awe of this game
man I'm in all of it
it is breathtaking Colton it is
I know Jenny I just got it I just got to
Winter and I'm just like literally
flying around to take it all in
I think winter makes some of the best I
mean just
photos I love like scenes of winter
I've talked about this before on stream
like any any game when you have a winter
or a snowy area
they're always some of my favorite areas
Metroid Prime which just got
the remaster just got announced earlier
today
one of my favorite levels is the snow
the snow level findrana drifts
I can still hear the music in my head
all these years later
and this is the Onyx hippogriff Mount as
well guys the one you got if you
pre-ordered any version of the game
you'll get you'll get the Onyx
hippogriff
honestly can't believe this is real
right
right it actually lived up
it actually lived up to our expectations
guys
[Music]
oh this looks like a little cave right
here
I want to go check this out
[Music]
oh no
what is that
Rebellion perfect
oh oh there's something going on down
there
hello sir
actually you know what you know what I'm
right I'm just like after that crazy
fight I'm just ready for some more
insane combat
thank you
I would say the diet oh flavor of wicked
to be to be our dark hearts
come on I'm dying to make me a few
sickles
well these guys are a little 20 they're
about to get wrecked
about to get wrecked I think we're
almost 26.
oh there's a bunch I didn't know there
were so many
oh yeah back to back you like that you
like that okay
oh
my screen everything had been going so
well and then it just started
flickering again
I think we got them all though
I think we got them all
yeah Taylor I've been playing on
performance
give me those frames give me those
frames
which it still looks I think it still
looks great but it there's no denying
you put it on Fidelity and it is uh it
is a step up
a step up in the visual quality but it
just feels too much like a
I'm just so used to playing 60 and above
now that 30 feels so
it's like a slideshow almost to me
all right have you already done this
Merlin puzzle yeah we have otherwise it
wouldn't be appearing like that
all right man we just unlocked winter I
don't want to rush it I don't want to
rush through winter so
I think I'm gonna call it there man
I think I'm gonna call it there what a
stream though what a stream thank you
guys for hanging out
this has been a lot of fun appreciate
all the new Subs I know there are a lot
of new Subs coming through tonight
the new members we also had Andrew stop
by with another insane donation
a couple super chats in there as well
dreaming
and Patrick
thank you guys very much man this has
been a really fun stream we are going to
be live again tomorrow on Twitch
I should have gotten to bed sooner so I
could get on earlier
but I don't know probably around you
know sometime before definitely before
noon definitely before noon we'll be
live over on Twitch and we'll have the
drops active again so if you guys didn't
get the drops yet
you can't get Merlin unless you watch
the official Avalanche stream
which they're gonna do another one on
Friday so if you haven't got that you'll
have a chance to get that there
dreaming with another Super Chat thank
you dreaming
good night retro thanks for another
great stream
I appreciate it appreciate you
[Music]
appreciate you and all your support guys
all your support
almost bedtime definitely yours oh yeah
it's almost 1am
and I got a video I gotta record
I gotta record a video for you guys
dude we had some epic moments though
tonight
did we not like some epic moments we had
an epic moment with a dragon epic moment
with a hippogriff epic moment with
ridiculous like
realm-shifting puzzles
realm-shifting bosses
and
then we got to winter so I feel like
that's a great way to end it
great way to end it grind don't stop you
got it
Shacks what's up Shacks I didn't know
you were here
good night Rye
my my marani new viewer fun watching hey
welcome thank you for stopping by glad
you enjoyed it the dragon that
that was insane if you guys depending on
when you hopped in and watched the
stream
go back later or you can even go back
now because YouTube makes it really easy
to skip back and forth if you if you
kind of skim through and find where I
rescue High Wing it's right at the very
end of that like after we rescue High
Wing we're flying away I'm still on the
hippogriff
and we just had this like the most epic
moment with a dragon
it was so awesome
so awesome Jenny thank you for being
here all your help tonight
Colton good to see you all right guys
the grind don't stop we'll be back at it
tomorrow don't know what time yet
because we stayed up too late tonight
and we got to stay up a little bit later
to do more videos for you guys gotta
keep the Hogwarts Legacy content train
rolling
but man I just can't get enough of this
game right now can't get enough of it
all right thank you all so much
everybody have a good night good morning
good afternoon wherever you may be as
always thank you all so much for
watching and I will talk to you all
again soon
see you later